Take back your free time with PC Express Online Grocery Delivery and Pickup. Get in-store promos, PC Optimum Points, and more free time. And still get groceries. Shop now at pcexpress.ca. The Paramount Plus exclusive series, The Agency. The CIA sends us out to behave in a dangerous way. Starring Michael Fassbender and Richard Gere. Whatever it takes, make it invisible.
使用 PC Express 在线杂货配送和自提服务，找回您的闲暇时光。享受店内促销、PC Optimum 积分以及更多空闲时间，同时还能买到生活杂货。立即前往 pcexpress.ca 选购。Paramount Plus 独家剧集《代理人》(The Agency)。中情局派我们去执行危险任务。由迈克尔·法斯宾德和理查·基尔主演。不惜一切代价，将其隐形。
The Agency, new series now streaming exclusively on Paramount+. Happy holidays, everyone. It's almost New Year's. Maybe as you're listening to this, you're running some last minute errands. Maybe your in-laws or some random cousins are on the way over.
《代理人》，全新剧集现已在 Paramount+ 独家上线。大家节日快乐。快到新年了。也许您在听这段节目时，正在忙着处理最后的一些琐事。也许您的姻亲或某位远房表亲正在赶来的路上。
Maybe you need a break from it all. Well, welcome to Second Drink, your little escape from the holiday frenzy. This week it is sexual harassment, and in this episode we meet Todd Packer for the first time. Now we had heard his voice on the phone, but this is the first time we meet him, and we talk all about the character of Todd Packer
也许您需要从这一切中解脱出来。那么，欢迎来到《第二杯》(Second Drink)，这是您从节日狂欢中获得的小小逃离。本周的主题是性骚扰，在这一集中，我们第一次见到了托德·帕克 (Todd Packer)。虽然我们之前在电话里听过他的声音，但这是我们第一次见到他，我们将深入探讨托德·帕克这个角色。
and Dave Keckner shares his memories with us. But Angela, you said you found something that we missed. I did. You know, I've been going back and rereading the shooting drafts, and lady, we never shared what the stage direction said about Todd Packer. There is a fantastic character description. I want you to hear it. Here's how it read.
戴夫·科克纳 (Dave Keckner) 与我们分享了他的回忆。但是安吉拉，你说你发现了一些我们遗漏的东西。是的。你知道，我回去重读了拍摄剧本，天哪，我们从来没有分享过剧本中关于托德·帕克的舞台指示。有一段非常精彩的角色描述。我想让你听听。它是这样写的。
Interior office reception area. The door flies open. Pam turns hopefully. Nope, it's Todd Packer striding in like he owns it. Packer is taller than average, larger than life, and irresistibly colorful alpha male bully. Much more fun to watch than to suffer through. Isn't that a great description?
室内，办公室接待区。门猛地打开。帕姆充满希望地转过头。不，是托德·帕克，他大步走进来，仿佛这里是他家一样。帕克身材高大，充满活力，是一个不可抗拒的、色彩鲜明的阿尔法男性恶霸。看他比忍受他要有趣得多。这不是一段很棒的描述吗？
That is a really good description. And then you know there's that hilarious talking head that Michael has. It's in the episode where he says that Todd Packer and I are like BFFs. And right after it, there was more stage direction about how Michael would act around Todd Packer. I thought it was really funny. Here's what it said, cut to Michael. Michael is adoring, worshipful, like talking about a gorgeous woman who also saved his life and taught him to ride a bike. Well, that is BJ Novak for you.
那确实是一段非常好的描述。还有，你知道迈克尔那个搞笑的“谈话头”片段吗？就在那一集里，他说托德·帕克和我是最好的朋友。在那之后，还有一段关于迈克尔在托德·帕克身边表现的舞台指示。我觉得非常有趣。它是这样写的，切到迈克尔。迈克尔表现得崇拜、敬畏，就像在谈论一位救过他命并教他骑自行车的绝世美女。好吧，这就是 BJ·诺瓦克 (BJ Novak) 的风格。
He writes the best descriptions. Well, that is BJ Novak for you. He writes the best descriptions. I mean, he's the one that wrote in Diversity Day that when Pam falls asleep on Jim's shoulder, it's as if a butterfly had landed on his shoulder. Yeah, that's true. That's how Jim feels that moment. Well, that's some good BJ stage direction right there. Jenna, we also got some fan mail, and apparently I missed a really good Pam Sass moment.
他写出的描述总是最棒的。好吧，这就是 BJ·诺瓦克。他写出的描述总是最棒的。我的意思是，他在《多元化日》(Diversity Day) 里写道，当帕姆在吉姆的肩膀上睡着时，就像一只蝴蝶落在了他的肩膀上。是的，那是真的。那一刻吉姆就是那种感觉。好吧，那确实是 BJ 写出的精彩舞台指示。珍娜，我们还收到了一些粉丝来信，显然我错过了一个帕姆非常“毒舌”的时刻。
Oh yes, this was right when you were picking up on all the sass. All the sass. So you know Todd Packer's talking and he gestures towards Ryan and he says, don't let this little bitch drive you around town, we got lost for like half an hour. And then Pam says, I don't have any DUI so I can drive myself but thanks I'm in. I have to agree that's some Pam sass. Good Pam sass. Well we also got a letter a lot of people wrote in to ask if we heard the goat sound. There's this scene outside the warehouse where the guys are heckling Michael, listen, I don't hear the goat. Do you hear it?
哦，是的，这正是你开始注意到所有“毒舌”的时候。所有的“毒舌”。所以你知道托德·帕克在说话，他指着瑞恩说，别让这个小婊子开车带你到处转，我们迷路了大概半小时。然后帕姆说，我没有酒驾记录，所以我可以自己开车，但谢谢你的邀请。我不得不承认，那确实是帕姆的“毒舌”。很棒的帕姆式“毒舌”。好吧，我们还收到了一封信，很多人写信来问我们是否听到了山羊的声音。在仓库外面的那个场景里，男人们在嘲讽迈克尔，听着，我没听到山羊的声音。你听到了吗？
Let's play it. I didn't hear it the first time, but then I went back and I heard it. Okay, well, let's listen. Oh, okay. That one's still about me. Hey, hey, hey. So you don't have the biggest package. Don't feel bad.
我们来放一下。我第一次没听到，但后来我回去听，听到了。好吧，我们来听听。哦，好吧。那个还是关于我的。嘿，嘿，嘿。所以你的“家伙”不是最大的。别觉得难过。
I don't feel bad. I think he feels bad. No, I don't. You look like you feel bad. Okay. Just a little package. Well, you don't feel bad. I think he feels bad. No, I don't. You look like you feel bad. Okay. Just a little package. Well, you know, not exactly what I was looking for,
我不觉得难过。我觉得他觉得难过。不，我没有。你看上去像觉得难过。好吧。只是有点小。好吧，你并不觉得难过。我觉得他觉得难过。不，我没有。你看上去像觉得难过。好吧。只是有点小。好吧，你知道，这不完全是我想要的，
but thanks guys. Thank you. You look good in the package. He came from his mama. Right? Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah. Yeah. Oh, oh, there I heard it.
但谢谢你们，伙计们。谢谢。你看起来很适合这个“家伙”。他是他妈妈生的，对吧？是啊，是啊，是啊，是啊。是啊。哦，哦，我听到了。
I heard it because I think I wasn't watching it. I know. What is that? Is one of the guys making that sound? It's one of the office workers. I know that because my brother always does that from this episode. Oh my gosh, Sam. No way.
我听到了，因为我想我当时没在看画面。我知道。那是什么？是其中一个人发出的声音吗？是办公室职员之一。我知道这一点，因为我哥哥总是模仿这一集里的那个声音。天哪，萨姆。不会吧。
You know, it's funny. I could hear a horn honk in the background, so I'm like listening so intently. And then yes, there it was. So clearly a goat. Well finally, when we broke down this episode, I shared that there was a very funny runner in deleted scenes where Michael is just going off on Toby. Just like, it goes on and on and on. This runner of him just.
你知道，这很有趣。我能听到背景里有喇叭声，所以我听得非常专注。然后，是的，就在那儿。很明显是山羊的声音。最后，当我们拆解这一集时，我分享过在删减片段里有一个非常有趣的连贯情节，迈克尔一直在针对托比。就像，没完没了。这个连贯情节里他一直在……
He's sitting at his desk. Yeah. And it's like every crappy thing he's thought about Toby is just coming out. Like stream of consciousness. They have been added to the end of the superfan episode for sexual harassment. It's really fun. I think we should hear them.
他坐在办公桌前。是的。就像他脑子里所有关于托比的糟糕想法都涌出来了。就像意识流一样。它们被添加到了《性骚扰》这一集的“超级粉丝”版结尾。真的很有趣。我觉得我们应该听听。
And we have your stupid rules to blame, Toby. Toby actually gets alimony from his ex-wife because she makes more. So that's kind of embarrassing. Not that I'd mind, but it would never happen to me because I would make the marriage work. People seem to like him because they think he's one of us, but he's not, he's this weird loner who just tells people don't do this, don't do that,
我们要怪你那些愚蠢的规定，托比。托比实际上从他前妻那里拿赡养费，因为她赚得更多。所以那有点尴尬。并不是说我介意，但这永远不会发生在我身上，因为我会经营好婚姻。人们似乎喜欢他，因为他们认为他是我们的一员，但他不是，他是个奇怪的独行侠，只会告诉别人不要做这个，不要做那个，
hire this person for this reason. I would complain about him, but who would I go to to complain about Toby? Toby. Bias. And what does he do about that? Nothing, because he's Toby. What kind of name is that? It's almost a girl's name. I think I've known more girls named Toby than guys. He just kind of makes my skin crawl a little bit.
因为这个原因雇佣这个人。我会投诉他，但我能去找谁投诉托比呢？托比。偏见。他对此做了什么？什么都没做，因为他是托比。那是什么名字？那几乎是个女孩的名字。我想我认识的叫托比的女孩比男孩多。他只是让我觉得有点毛骨悚然。
Toby is the devil. Toby's the devil. I love Michael hating Toby. I love it so much. So much. Well, we will see you next Monday for second drink of Office Olympics. And then next Wednesday, January 8th, we are back for our episode,
托比是魔鬼。托比是魔鬼。我喜欢迈克尔讨厌托比。我太喜欢了。太喜欢了。好吧，我们下周一再见，届时将播出《办公室奥运会》(Office Olympics) 的《第二杯》。然后是下周三，1月8日，我们回来讨论我们的剧集，
Is Toby the Scranton Strangler? With special guest, Paul Lieberstein. And now here is sexual harassment. I'm Jenna Fischer. And I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together. And we're best friends. And now we're doing the ultimate office rewatch podcast
《托比是斯克兰顿勒杀手吗？》(Is Toby the Scranton Strangler?)，特邀嘉宾是保罗·利伯斯坦 (Paul Lieberstein)。现在，这是《性骚扰》。我是珍娜·费舍尔 (Jenna Fischer)。我是安吉拉·金赛 (Angela Kinsey)。我们曾一起出演《办公室》(The Office)。我们是最好的朋友。现在我们正在制作终极的《办公室》重温播客，
just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind the scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office ladies. Welcome to The Office ladies. Welcome everybody. Today we're talking about the episode sexual harassment. Oh, it's a doozy
专为您打造。每周我们将拆解《办公室》的一集，并提供只有身临其境的两个人才能告诉您的独家幕后故事。我们是《办公室女士》(Office Ladies)。欢迎来到《办公室女士》。大家好。今天我们要讨论的是《性骚扰》这一集。哦，这可真是个棘手的家伙。
And if you're listening with your kids, we're gonna try to keep it clean folks. Yeah, maybe you want to pre-screen this one Yeah, I mean the subject matter alone I know well They had to walk a line when they were writing and making this episode and we're gonna walk a line today talking about it Angela I see you're eating a Pop-Tart. Yes, I am. It's a brown sugar Pop-Tart. Brown sugar?
如果您和孩子们一起听，我们要尽量保持内容纯洁，伙计们。是的，也许您想先预审一下这一集。是的，我的意思是光是主题内容我就知道。好吧，他们在编写和制作这一集时必须小心翼翼，我们今天讨论它时也会小心翼翼。安吉拉，我看到你在吃 Pop-Tart。是的，我在吃。是红糖味的 Pop-Tart。红糖？
I didn't know cinnamon or brown sugar. It has some brown icing on it. This is how- I think it's the cinnamon brown sugar Pop-Tart. Am I right, guys, in the booth? Yeah, it's the cinnamon brown sugar Pop-Tart. This has been a sticking point in my friendship with Angela for a long time, which
我不知道是肉桂还是红糖。上面有一些棕色的糖霜。这是怎么……我觉得是肉桂红糖味的 Pop-Tart。我说对了吗，展位里的伙计们？是的，是肉桂红糖味的 Pop-Tart。这长期以来一直是我和安吉拉友谊中的一个症结，那就是
is that she can eat things like Pop- Tarts, donuts, pancakes for breakfast. This is a bad time for me to tell you, I also had two muffins before the Pop Tart. It is. It is. All right, guys, today is Sexual Harassment Season Two, Episode Two. This was written by BJ Novak and directed by Ken Quapis.
她早餐可以吃 Pop-Tarts、甜甜圈、煎饼之类的东西。现在告诉你这个时机很糟糕，我在吃 Pop-Tart 之前还吃了两个松饼。确实是。确实是。好了，伙计们，今天是《性骚扰》，第二季第二集。这是由 BJ·诺瓦克编写，肯·夸皮斯 (Ken Quapis) 执导的。
You've probably heard those names before. I want to point out in my first fast fact that BJ Novak wrote Diversity Day and Ken Quapus directed it. So they already had a little bit of a great back and forth. Yes, they are paired together again. I guess Greg assigned BJ the script of sexual harassment because of the good job he had done on Diversity Day. On touchy subjects.
你们可能以前听过这些名字。我想在我的第一个速记事实中指出，BJ·诺瓦克编写了《多元化日》，而肯·夸皮斯执导了它。所以他们已经有了一次很棒的合作。是的，他们又被配对在一起了。我想格雷格 (Greg) 把《性骚扰》的剧本分配给 BJ，是因为他在《多元化日》中表现出色。在处理敏感话题方面。
Yes. Oh, well, and then Ken was asked to direct it. I think it makes sense. Ken Quapus is such a gentleman. BJ is so smart. He's able to walk that line so well. I think this was the perfect coupling. I do too.
是的。哦，好吧，然后肯被邀请执导。我觉得这很有道理。肯·夸皮斯是一位真正的绅士。BJ 非常聪明。他能够很好地把握那个尺度。我觉得这是完美的组合。我也这么认为。
Bring this episode to life. Here's a quick summary for this episode. When an upper level manager is let go because of sexual harassment, corporate requires everyone in the company to undergo sexual harassment training. Michael's crude friend, Todd Packer, comes into the office and starts harassing everyone.
让这一集变得生动起来。这是这一集的简要总结。当一名高层经理因性骚扰被解雇时，公司要求公司里的每个人都接受性骚扰培训。迈克尔粗俗的朋友托德·帕克来到办公室，开始骚扰每个人。
Kind of a twofer there. There you go. In years later, we would have our own seminars that NBC would have us attend. We've talked about this. And they would use clips from this episode of what not to do at work. And other episodes.
那算是一箭双雕吧。给你。多年后，我们会有自己的研讨会，NBC 会让我们参加。我们谈过这个。他们会使用这一集里的片段作为工作中不该做的事情的例子。还有其他剧集。
And other episodes. We're like, oh, hey, it's us again. Oh, yeah, no one should be doing that. OK, OK, good. And also, after reading the scripts, the network originally wanted to air sexual harassment as our season premiere for season two. I know.
还有其他剧集。我们就像，哦，嘿，又是我们。哦，是的，没人应该那样做。好的，好的，很好。而且，在阅读剧本后，电视网最初想把《性骚扰》作为我们第二季的首播集。我知道。
Probably good that we eased into that one. It is because this brings me to my second fast fact, which is that this episode originally aired with a warning. It did? Yes, which is very unusual for network television. Oh, I didn't know that. It aired with a warning before the episode that said, this episode contains adult content and subject matter.
可能我们慢慢进入状态比较好。确实如此，因为这引出了我的第二个速记事实，那就是这一集最初播出时带有警告。真的吗？是的，这对于电视网来说非常罕见。哦，我不知道。它在播出前有一个警告，说：本集包含成人内容和主题。
Oh. Yeah. And you know why? All right, parents, this is where you're going to want to start. Maybe mute us for 15 seconds. Maybe put the earmuffs on. Earmuffs. Earmuffs on the kids.
哦。是的。而且你知道为什么吗？好了，家长们，这是你们要开始注意的地方。也许把我们静音15秒。也许给孩子们戴上耳罩。耳罩。给孩子们戴上耳罩。
It all came down to the word boner. Yes, with Phyllis. With Phyllis. The scene with Phyllis at the end when Steve says something like, no, I'm just afraid I'll get a boner, the network wanted to change it to, I'm afraid I'll get a shwing. And they...
这一切都归结于“硬挺”(boner) 这个词。是的，和菲利斯 (Phyllis) 有关。和菲利斯有关。在结尾菲利斯的那一幕，当史蒂夫 (Steve) 说类似“不，我只是怕我会硬挺”的话时，电视网想把它改成“我怕我会‘嗖’的一下”。他们……
What is it, Wayne's World? NBC is like, let's make it Wayne's World. Let's make it a shwing. I'm afraid I'll get a shwing. Yeah. And BJ fought to keep boner in the episode. The warning was their way of having a compromise. We were surprised that Clitoris madeer in the episode. The warning was their way of having a compromise. We were surprised that Clitoris made it in the episode. I mean, there's a whole runner with a blow-up doll.
这是什么，《韦恩的世界》(Wayne's World) 吗？NBC 就像是，让我们把它变成《韦恩的世界》。让我们把它变成“嗖”。我怕我会“嗖”的一下。是的。BJ 极力争取在剧集中保留“硬挺”这个词。警告是他们达成妥协的方式。我们很惊讶“阴蒂”(Clitoris) 这个词竟然出现在了剧集中。我的意思是，有一个关于充气娃娃的完整连贯情节。
Right? Pam's supposed to kiss a blow-up doll. There's, to me, many red flags here. A lot of stuff happening. But they got stuck on Boner. They got stuck on Boner. Sorry. Oh, boy.
对吧？帕姆应该亲吻一个充气娃娃。对我来说，这里有很多危险信号。发生了很多事情。但他们卡在了“硬挺”这个词上。他们卡在了“硬挺”上。抱歉。哦，天哪。
There's too many. That's what she says in this episode. OK, parents. That could be a drinking game on boner. Sorry. Oh boy. There's too many. That's what she says in this episode. Okay, parents. That could be a drinking game for this episode. Wow. We don't condone that. I make this as mature. Okay. But even still, even with the warning, there was one network in Kentucky that refused to air this episode. Oh really? Yeah. So we- Sorry, Kentucky. We got pulled off the air. You can watch it on Netflix right now, folks in Kentucky. That is so funny to me because the word boner, sorry to go back there, is so funny, Phyllis's reaction to the word boner.
太多了。这就是她在这一集里说的话。好的，家长们。那可以成为一个关于“硬挺”的饮酒游戏。抱歉。哦，天哪。太多了。这就是她在这一集里说的话。好的，家长们。那可以成为这一集的饮酒游戏。哇。我们不纵容那样做。我让这变得成熟。好的。但即便如此，即使有警告，肯塔基州还是有一个电视网拒绝播出这一集。哦，真的吗？是的。所以我们——抱歉，肯塔基州。我们被停播了。肯塔基州的伙计们，你们现在可以在 Netflix 上看了。这对我来说太搞笑了，因为“硬挺”这个词——抱歉又回到这个话题——太搞笑了，菲利斯对“硬挺”这个词的反应。
Yes. It wouldn't be the same if it was swing. It wouldn't be the same. It wouldn't be the same. And for me, what made that moment funny was Phyllis. Her look to Michael when he said it was hilarious. So, okay, moving on. We can talk more about that scene later in the episode.
是的。如果改成“嗖”就不会有同样的效果了。不会一样的。不会一样的。对我来说，让那一刻变得有趣的是菲利斯。她听到迈克尔说那个词时看向他的表情太搞笑了。所以，好吧，继续。我们可以在这一集后面再多谈谈那个场景。
I have a lot to say about that scene. Oh, gosh, more? Okay. My third fast fact is that we get to meet Todd Packer, finally! The Todd Packer in the flesh comes into the office played by Dave Keckner. Okay, so I have known Dave Keckner, oh my gosh, maybe 16 years. I've known him a really long time. We met back at Improv Olympic. He had taken Second City in Chicago and he knew Steve from Second City and Nancy, Steve's
关于那个场景我有很多话要说。哦，天哪，还有更多？好的。我的第三个速记事实是我们终于见到了托德·帕克！托德·帕克本人来到了办公室，由戴夫·科克纳饰演。好的，所以我认识戴夫·科克纳，天哪，大概16年了。我认识他很长时间了。我们在即兴奥林匹克 (Improv Olympic) 认识的。他参加过芝加哥的第二城 (Second City)，他从第二城认识史蒂夫，还有南希，史蒂夫的
wife, Nancy. I called Dave last night and I was like, Dave, we're going to do sexual harassment. And he was like, do you have people come in the booth? I was like, we do, Dave, can you come in tomorrow? And he's like, nah, I'm working. I was like, okay. And then I said, oh, Dave, can I record our conversation? He's like, yeah, sure, tell me when you're ready to go.
妻子，南希。我昨晚给戴夫打电话，我说，戴夫，我们要讨论《性骚扰》。他说，你们有嘉宾来展位吗？我说，有的，戴夫，你明天能来吗？他说，不，我在工作。我说，好吧。然后我说，哦，戴夫，我可以录下我们的谈话吗？他说，可以，准备好了告诉我。
Oh, this is great. Yes, it's great. So I did the swipe up on my iPhone, you know where your flashlight is? Sure. You know, underneath, like by your flashlight. I know my phone. Okay, there's a little- I know my phone. Okay, there's a little record button.
哦，这太棒了。是的，太棒了。所以我用 iPhone 向上滑动，你知道手电筒在哪里吗？当然。你知道，在下面，就在手电筒旁边。我了解我的手机。好的，有一个小……我了解我的手机。好的，有一个小录音按钮。
Okay. So I hit the record button and I was like, let's do this. I'm feeling like this isn't going where we're hoping. Okay. Dave and I talked for half an hour. Yeah. I have 30 minutes- Okay.
好的。所以我按下了录音按钮，我说，开始吧。我觉得这进展得不像我们希望的那样。好的。戴夫和我谈了半小时。是的。我有30分钟——好的。
Of me filming my screen- Yeah. With no sound. Okay. Okay. It's a record button. How was I supposed to know it doesn't record sound? I don't know where to begin with this one.
我拍摄屏幕的视频——是的。没有声音。好的。好的。这是录音按钮。我怎么会知道它不录声音呢？我不知道从哪里开始说这个。
Is it because I'm 100 years old? Well, it's just that that's sort of like when my mom wrote me my first email. She called me on the phone and said, why haven't you responded to my email that I sent you? And I said, well, I never got your email. What email address did you send it to? And she said, I sent it to you. I sent it to Jenna. And I said, I don't understand. And she said, I opened the email box and it said, to, and I wrote Jenna. She just sent an email to Jenna. That is very similar to what you've done here with the record button on your phone.
是因为我100岁了吗？好吧，这有点像我妈妈第一次给我写电子邮件的时候。她给我打电话说，为什么你不回复我发给你的邮件？我说，好吧，我没收到你的邮件。你发到哪个邮箱地址了？她说，我发给你了。我发给珍娜了。我说，我不明白。她说，我打开邮件框，上面写着“收件人”，我就写了珍娜。她只是发了一封邮件给“珍娜”。这和你刚才在手机上按录音按钮的操作非常相似。
A little bit. Come on. A little bit. Wait a minute. It's kind of. with the record button on your phone a little bit. Come on now. A little bit. Wait a minute. It's kinda. Anyway, whatever guys. The long story short here is Dave,
有一点。拜托。有一点。等一下。这有点……在手机上按录音按钮。拜托。有一点。等一下。这有点……总之，伙计们，不管怎样。长话短说，戴夫，
thank you so much for talking to me last night for half an hour and I broke down everything we talked about because it didn't record. You do have a gazillion note cards today. Angela had to move seats because she has so many note cards. I have so many note cards. I have lots of little fun tidbits from Dave, but I'll save those as we go.
非常感谢你昨晚和我谈了半小时，我把你说的每一件事都整理出来了，因为没录上。你今天确实有无数张笔记卡。安吉拉不得不换座位，因为她有太多的笔记卡。我有太多的笔记卡。我从戴夫那里得到很多有趣的小花絮，但我会留着以后再说。
Okay, that's great. Something I'd like to expand on is what you were saying about Steve Carell starting at Second City in Chicago. I think a lot of people don't realize the long journey that a lot of us took before we landed on the office, and in particular, Steve Carell. He was doing comedy in Chicago on Second City for a very, very long time. And then he and his wife, Nancy, they moved to New York
好的，那太棒了。我想扩展一下你刚才说的关于史蒂夫·卡瑞尔 (Steve Carell) 在芝加哥第二城开始职业生涯的事情。我觉得很多人没有意识到我们在进入《办公室》之前所经历的长途跋涉，特别是史蒂夫·卡瑞尔。他在芝加哥的第二城做喜剧做了非常非常久。然后他和他的妻子南希搬到了纽约
City because she had an audition for Saturday Night Live. And she got it. She did. Her and Dave were on Saturday Night Live together. So they had known each other for a really long time and journeyed through quite a bit. And Steve was really excited. He is actually the one who pitched Dave to Greg for Todd Packer. He was really like, you got to cast Dave Kechner. They had just done Anchorman together.
市，因为她要去参加《周六夜现场》(Saturday Night Live) 的试镜。她成功了。她确实成功了。她和戴夫一起参加了《周六夜现场》。所以他们认识很久了，一起经历了很多。史蒂夫真的很兴奋。实际上是他向格雷格推荐戴夫出演托德·帕克。他真的很坚持，你一定要选戴夫·科克纳。他们刚一起拍完《王牌播音员》(Anchorman)。
And he just knew that they'd be off to the races and it'd be so much fun. And their dynamic in Anchorman was amazing. Their chemistry there was amazing, but it makes sense because they had been schlepping through Chicago to New York to LA together doing comedy for close to 15 years. Oh, yeah.
他知道他们会一拍即合，会非常有趣。他们在《王牌播音员》里的互动太棒了。他们的化学反应太棒了，但这说得通，因为他们一起在芝加哥、纽约和洛杉矶摸爬滚打做了近15年的喜剧。哦，是的。
They'd known each other for so long. And you were in those circles, Angela. I never got into that. I never did the comedy improv sketch comedy thing. Yes. I had met Dave years ago at Improv Olympic out here in Los Angeles. It was called IO West, and he was part
他们认识太久了。安吉拉，你也在那些圈子里。我从来没进去过。我从来没做过即兴喜剧小品。是的。我几年前在洛杉矶的即兴奥林匹克见过戴夫。它叫 IO West，他是
of a phenomenal improv show called Beer Shark Mice. These guys were amazing. They were like the best of the best. It would sell out. It would be standing room only. They were amazing. It was Mike Coleman, Pat Finn, Neil Flynn, and Pete Holney, Dave, Neil Flynn, and Pete
一个非凡的即兴表演节目“啤酒鲨鱼老鼠”(Beer Shark Mice) 的一部分。这些家伙太棒了。他们是精英中的精英。门票总是售罄。总是座无虚席。他们太棒了。有迈克·科尔曼 (Mike Coleman)、帕特·芬恩 (Pat Finn)、尼尔·弗林 (Neil Flynn) 和皮特·霍尔尼 (Pete Holney)、戴夫、尼尔·弗林和皮特·
Holney, Dave Kechner, and then also Paul Vallencourt. They were just phenomenal. Wow, what a show. It was it was great. So like, listen, if you're an improv nerd out there, these guys are the best of the best. I was working in the light booth, I was in charge of calling their lights. And I was really intimidated because the person in the light booth makes it fade to black when you feel that the show has wrapped up
霍尔尼、戴夫·科克纳，还有保罗·瓦伦考特 (Paul Vallencourt)。他们简直太非凡了。哇，真是场精彩的演出。太棒了。所以，听着，如果你是一个即兴表演迷，这些家伙是精英中的精英。我在灯光室工作，负责控制他们的灯光。我真的很紧张，因为灯光室的人要在你觉得演出结束时把灯光调暗。
So what kind of on you to decide on me and here I am like you're like a person lowering the curtain at the end of the show Yes, and I'm just like a newbie at the theater like I'm like really you're gonna trust me was there no one else and so I was calling lights and I Really felt like the show wrapped up and it was about 30 minutes and I pulled it to black and they were like, what? And then afterwards, Dave and everyone was like, Ange, we had a whole nother round to go. You called the lights way too soon. And I was like, I am so sorry. I'm so sorry. I felt so horrible. All right. So it's the next week and Dave comes up to me and says,
所以你决定什么时候结束，而我在这里就像一个在演出结束时拉幕的人。是的，我当时就像剧院里的新手，我心想，真的吗？你要信任我？没有别人了吗？所以我控制着灯光，我真的觉得演出结束了，大概30分钟，我把灯光调暗了，他们就像，什么？然后之后，戴夫和每个人都说，安吉，我们还有整整一轮要演。你太早调暗灯光了。我说，我太抱歉了。我太抱歉了。我感觉太糟糕了。好吧，那是下周，戴夫走过来对我说，
Ange, let us go about 45 minutes tonight. I'm like, okay, Dave, got it. Set my timer. You set a timer. I love that. I set a timer. That's very Jenna of you. Thank you. Yes. I didn't wanna get it wrong.
安吉，今晚让我们演45分钟。我说，好的，戴夫，明白了。设置我的计时器。你设置了计时器。我喜欢这一点。我设置了计时器。这很“珍娜”。谢谢。是的。我不想弄错。
So anyway, I'm up in the light booth at 39 minutes. I thought they had their out, Jenna. Okay. I did not pull lights. You did, no. No, and then they went to 45 minutes, I thought they had their out, Jenna. Okay. I did not pull lights. You did, no. No. And then they went to 45 minutes. And then it was almost an hour.
总之，我在39分钟时在灯光室。我以为他们已经演完了，珍娜。好的。我没有调暗灯光。你调了，不。不。然后他们演到了45分钟。然后快一个小时了。
What? I didn't wanna pull the lights. I didn't, I was too nervous. I don't know, I froze. They're probably just out there just flailing on stage. It was getting awkward. And Dave walks backstage and someone had left, I don't know, a spare tire to like a truck
什么？我不想调暗灯光。我不想，我太紧张了。我不知道，我僵住了。他们可能只是在台上不知所措。气氛变得很尴尬。戴夫走到后台，有人留下了一个，我不知道，一个卡车或吉普车的备用轮胎。
or a Jeep. It was enormous. So Dave gets this giant tire and he rolls it across the stage into the audience. And he's like, that's our show, you guys. And I was like, oh crap, oh crap. Wait, did you, when the tire went across the stage, did you finally go to Black Ange? I did. Okay.
它太巨大了。所以戴夫拿了这个巨大的轮胎，把它滚过舞台滚进观众席。他说，这就是我们的表演，伙计们。我说，哦糟了，哦糟了。等等，当轮胎滚过舞台时，你终于调暗灯光了吗，安吉？我调了。好的。
So you got his signal then. I got it. I got it, got his signal then. I got it. I got it, Dave. The tire. I got it. And I went backstage and I was like, you guys. And we all started cracking up and they still talk about it. They still talk about the tire.
所以你收到了他的信号。我收到了。我收到了，收到了他的信号。我收到了。我收到了，戴夫。轮胎。我收到了。我走到后台说，你们这些家伙。我们都开始大笑，他们至今还在谈论这件事。他们还在谈论那个轮胎。
Anyway, I just love those guys so much. And believe it or not, I did call lights for them a few more times until they got their official person. But that is how I met Dave Keckner. Didn't Greg Daniels go to a few of those shows? I mean, maybe not Dave's in particular, but. Oh no, Greg loved supporting like small improv theaters and a lot of improvisers ended up on our show.
总之，我太喜欢那些家伙了。信不信由你，我确实又为他们调了几次灯光，直到他们有了正式的人选。但这就是我认识戴夫·科克纳的方式。格雷格·丹尼尔斯 (Greg Daniels) 没去看过那几场演出吗？我的意思是，也许不是戴夫的特别演出，但是。哦不，格雷格喜欢支持像小型即兴剧院这样的地方，很多即兴表演者最终都出现在我们的节目中。
So I know Rainn Wilson would make fun of me, but I'd be like, oh, you know, whoever actor is showing up. I did a Sunday show with him. He'd be like, did you do improv with Amanda Love? Like, yes, Rainn. Well, Rainn and I were the two classically trained theater actors. Oh, don't we know it. Oh, don't we know it. I heard quite a bit about it. All right, before things take a turn here, maybe we should go to a break. Yeah, let's go to a break. Tis the season to treat your family to the great taste of Popeyes. The festive family box is here to make your holidays brighter with all your Popeyes favorites.
所以我知道雷恩·威尔森 (Rainn Wilson) 会取笑我，但我会说，哦，你知道，不管哪个演员出现。我和他一起演过周日场。他会说，你和阿曼达·洛夫 (Amanda Love) 一起做过即兴表演吗？是的，雷恩。好吧，雷恩和我都是受过古典训练的戏剧演员。哦，我们知道。哦，我们知道。我听过不少关于这个的事。好了，在事情发生转折之前，也许我们应该休息一下。是的，让我们休息一下。这是用 Popeyes 的美味款待家人的季节。节日家庭套餐在这里，用你所有最喜欢的 Popeyes 美食让你的假期更明亮。
For just $25, you'll get four pieces of delicious Popeyes signature chicken, four tasty chicken tenders, four regular size and everybody's favorite, 4 buttermilk biscuits. Hurry up though, like the holiday season, Popeye's $25 Fist of Family Box deal will be over before you know it. Love that chicken from Popeye's. With Uber Reserve, good things come to those who plan ahead. Family vacay?
只需25美元，你就能得到四块美味的 Popeyes 招牌炸鸡、四块美味的鸡柳、四份常规尺寸的配菜，以及每个人最喜欢的4块酪乳饼干。快点吧，就像节日一样，Popeyes 的25美元节日家庭套餐优惠很快就会结束。爱死 Popeyes 的炸鸡了。有了 Uber Reserve，提前计划的人会有好运。家庭度假？
Reserve your ride as soon as you book your flights. To all the planners, now you can reserve your Uber ride up to 90 days in advance. See Uber app for details. I am so dreading groceries this week. Why? You can skip it. Oh, what, just like that? Just like that.
预订航班后立即预订您的行程。致所有计划者，现在您可以提前90天预订您的 Uber 行程。详情请查看 Uber 应用程序。我真的很害怕这周去买杂货。为什么？你可以跳过它。哦，什么，就这样？就这样。
How about dinner with my third cousin? Skip it. Prince Fluffy's favorite treats? Skippable. Midnight snacks? Skip. My neighbor's nightly saxophone practices? Er, nope.
和我表亲吃晚餐怎么样？跳过。Fluffy 王子最喜欢的零食？可跳过。午夜零食？跳过。邻居每晚的萨克斯练习？呃，不。
You're on your own there. Could have skipped it. Should have skipped it. Skip to the good part and get groceries, meals, and more delivered right to your door on Skip. And we're back talking about the sexual harassment episode. Here we go. Here we go.
你自己解决吧。本可以跳过的。应该跳过的。跳到精彩的部分，在 Skip 上把杂货、餐点等直接送到你家门口。我们回来了，继续讨论《性骚扰》这一集。我们开始吧。我们开始吧。
Buckle in everyone. Buckle in as they say. In rewatching this episode, Angela, I was very uncomfortable. Yeah. I was more squirmy during this than diversity day. Well, yeah, I mean, I don't know. They're both equally squirmy for me. But then I was squirmy during Hot Girl. I think that I had forgotten how really cringey and
大家都系好安全带。系好安全带，正如他们所说。在重温这一集时，安吉拉，我感到非常不舒服。是的。我在这一集里比在《多元化日》里更坐立不安。好吧，是的，我的意思是，我不知道。对我来说它们同样让人坐立不安。但我看《辣妹》(Hot Girl) 时也坐立不安。我想我忘记了这部剧有时会变得多么令人尴尬和
uncomfortable the show can get sometimes. Oh, we pushed it. We pushed it to the line and then went over the line. How did this show get on the air? I mean, I know this particular episode got on with a warning, but in general, what was going on? I don't know. I mean, you know, I grew up overseas and I grew up with a lot of British television and they definitely pushed the line. And I think the show was in the spirit of the BBC version. And I don't know, I think like some of the cringy moments that you end up laughing, I don't know. I think some of the cringey moments that you end up laughing, I don't know.
不舒服。哦，我们推到了极限，然后越过了界限。这部剧是怎么播出的？我的意思是，我知道这一集是带着警告播出的，但总的来说，发生了什么？我不知道。我的意思是，你知道，我在海外长大，我从小看很多英国电视节目，他们绝对推到了极限。我觉得这部剧有 BBC 版本的精神。而且我不知道，我觉得你最终会笑出来的那些尴尬时刻，我不知道。我觉得你最终会笑出来的那些尴尬时刻，我不知道。
I love it. I know that Kevin Reilly, who was at NBC at the time, was a huge champion for our show. Huge. I really credit him with us sticking around. He believed in us. And there were a lot of people there who didn't get it and who didn't think that this was a good idea.
我喜欢它。我知道当时在 NBC 的凯文·赖利 (Kevin Reilly) 是我们节目的坚定支持者。非常坚定。我真的认为我们能留下来要归功于他。他相信我们。那里有很多人不理解，也不认为这是一个好主意。
No, it's true. He fought for us. And when we finally won an Emmy for Best Comedy Ensemble, we all went backstage for photos, and the guys, the cast picked up Kevin Reilly up in the air. And that's the photo that was in the LA Times, because we all knew that he put his neck on the line for us. And I mean, I'll always be grateful to Kevin for that.
不，这是真的。他为我们而战。当我们最终赢得艾美奖最佳喜剧群戏奖时，我们都去后台拍照，伙计们，演员们把凯文·赖利举了起来。那就是《洛杉矶时报》上的那张照片，因为我们都知道他为我们冒了险。我的意思是，我永远会为此感激凯文。
The episode begins with Michael walking up to Jim's desk to see if he has received his hilarious email forward. Michael has a talking head where he declares himself the king of forwards. And he says, that's how I like to do business. I have a funny story about a behind the scenes moment that happened on set while we were filming a big group scene in the bullpen
这一集开始于迈克尔走到吉姆的办公桌前，看他是否收到了他那搞笑的转发邮件。迈克尔有一个“谈话头”片段，他宣布自己是转发之王。他说，这就是我喜欢做生意的方式。我有一个关于幕后时刻的有趣故事，发生在我们在牛棚里拍摄一个大型集体场景时，
talking about these email forwards. And- Was I there? You were there. Okay, remind me. Everyone was there. Kelly was there, still with an up to. When is the episode where Kelly becomes Mindy?
谈论这些转发邮件。而且——我在场吗？你在场。好的，提醒我。每个人都在场。凯莉也在场，还在用……哪一集凯莉变成了敏迪 (Mindy)？
Exactly. That's what we need to look for. No, so this is an episode that John Krasinski and I will never forget because he about fell out of his chair. At nine minutes, 16 seconds, you know, we're talking about the email forwards, and Michael's really upset that they want him to stop doing this. And I say, I hate them. You send me these filthy emails and you say forward them to 10 people or you'll have bad luck. Right?
没错。这就是我们需要寻找的。不，所以这一集约翰·卡拉辛斯基 (John Krasinski) 和我永远不会忘记，因为他差点从椅子上掉下来。在9分16秒，你知道，我们在谈论转发邮件，迈克尔真的很生气，因为他们想让他停止这样做。我说，我讨厌它们。你发给我这些肮脏的邮件，你说转发给10个人，否则你会有厄运。对吧？
Yeah. That's my line. So we had been working on this scene for a while and then we went to lunch and we came back. Oh, that's always so hard to pick up a scene. Yes. With lunch in between. Yes. And I think it was like around three o'clock in the afternoon. Oh, everyone's real off at that time. Everyone's a little tired. People are a little bit more punchy. Yeah. And we're in a big group scene. So here's the thing you should know about me. I was born in Louisiana. My family's from Texas and Louisiana. I have a really, really hard time saying a vowel in front of an L. And two times in my
是的。那是我的台词。所以我们在这个场景上工作了一段时间，然后我们去吃午饭，然后我们回来了。哦，午饭后重新开始一个场景总是那么难。是的。中间有午饭。是的。我想大概是下午三点左右。哦，每个人在那时候都很累。每个人都稍微有点疲惫。人们稍微有点冲动。是的。我们在一个大型集体场景里。所以关于我，你应该知道一件事。我出生在路易斯安那州。我的家人来自德克萨斯州和路易斯安那州。我在 L 前面发元音真的非常非常困难。在我
career on The Office, they almost dropped a line because I could not say it. One time they actually did. I'll save that story for later. It was between Andy Bernard and myself. I couldn't say the line. I just kept sounding like such a hillbilly that they just dropped the line. But this line, I said, I hate them. You send me these filthy emails. And John about fell out of his chair and he went, the South has arrived. And I was like, what? What? I didn't even hear it. He was like, Angela. And like eight of you turned and looked at me. And at the same time, you was like, what? What? I didn't even hear it. He was like, Angela.
在《办公室》的职业生涯中，有两次他们差点删掉一句台词，因为我发不出那个音。有一次他们真的删了。我把那个故事留到以后再说。那是安迪·伯纳德 (Andy Bernard) 和我之间的。我发不出那句台词。我听起来就像个乡巴佬，他们就把那句台词删了。但这句台词，我说，我讨厌它们。你发给我这些肮脏的邮件。约翰差点从椅子上掉下来，他说，南方人来了。我说，什么？什么？我甚至没听到。他说，安吉拉。你们大概有八个人转过头看着我。同时，你就像，什么？什么？我甚至没听到。他说，安吉拉。
And like eight of you turned and looked at me. And at the same time, you were like, you said filthy. Filthy. And I said, how do you say it? And you're like, filthy. And I had to like really concentrate. Filthy, filthy. Because I automatically want to say filthy.
你们大概有八个人转过头看着我。同时，你说，你说的是“肮脏”(filthy)。肮脏。我说，你怎么发音？你说，肮脏。我不得不非常专注。肮脏，肮脏。因为我自动想说“肮脏”。
Filthy. But somewhere there's footage of me saying, you send me these filthy emails. And John lost it. You and John had a great relationship on the show. You guys were big brother, kid sister. And it was so sweet. I loved your banter. And I loved just, I don't know, you guys were really cute.
肮脏。但在某个地方有我说的片段，你发给我这些肮脏的邮件。约翰笑疯了。你和约翰在剧里关系很好。你们是哥哥和妹妹。这太甜了。我喜欢你们的玩笑。我喜欢，我不知道，你们真的很可爱。
You would tease one another. I know. He felt like my big brother, even though he's younger than me. Yes. But he did. He felt like my big brother that I teased. And he loved it. When I slipped into Southern Drawl,
你们会互相取笑。我知道。他感觉像我的哥哥，尽管他比我小。是的。但他确实是。他感觉像我取笑的哥哥。他很喜欢。当我滑入南方口音时，
he'd be like, well, hello. He loved it. So next up, Todd Packer comes in the office and boy, does Dave Keckner own a room when he enters that room. Yes. Dave told me last night on the phone,
他会说，哦，你好。他很喜欢。所以接下来，托德·帕克走进办公室，天哪，戴夫·科克纳走进那个房间时，他确实掌控了全场。是的。戴夫昨晚在电话里告诉我，
he said, Todd Packer just comes in and blows up your world and then kaboom leaves. No consequences. Mic drop. See you later. And then he's out. I have a little tidbit about Dave. Oh, tell me. Okay. So Dave told me he actually auditioned for Michael Scott. What? Yes. He had known Greg Daniels for years. He had done a pilot for one of Greg's writers
他说，托德·帕克只是走进来，炸毁了你的世界，然后砰的一声离开了。没有后果。扔下麦克风。回头见。然后他就走了。我有一个关于戴夫的小花絮。哦，告诉我。好的。所以戴夫告诉我他实际上试镜过迈克尔·斯科特。什么？是的。他认识格雷格·丹尼尔斯很多年了。他为格雷格的一位编剧拍过一部试播集
on King of the Hill. Yeah. He had known Greg Daniels for years. He had done a pilot for one of Greg's writers on King of the Hill. Yeah. So he knew Greg for a long time. And they brought him in for Michael Scott. And he said, Ange, I was obsessed with the BBC version. And all I had in my head was Ricky Gervais. I couldn't do it any other way.
在《山丘之王》(King of the Hill) 里。是的。所以他认识格雷格很久了。他们带他来试镜迈克尔·斯科特。他说，安吉，我沉迷于 BBC 版本。我脑子里只有瑞奇·热维斯 (Ricky Gervais)。我无法用其他方式来演。
So he was doing a little bit of an impersonation of Ricky. Yes. And I think a lot of people did that, that came in, but Steve had not seen it. And I think that really helped him kind of make his own person. Yeah. But he told me when they brought him in for Todd Packer,
所以他是在模仿瑞奇。是的。我觉得很多来试镜的人都那样做了，但史蒂夫没看过。我觉得这真的帮助他塑造了自己的角色。是的。但他告诉我，当他们带他来试镜托德·帕克时，
he was so excited. Because yes, it was based on Finchie, right, in the BBC version. Oh, yeah. So in the BBC version, David Brent has a friend named Chris Finch. And they call him Finchie. And he is the Todd Packer of the British show. Basically it's just this one-sided best
他非常兴奋。因为是的，它是基于 BBC 版本里的芬奇 (Finchie)，对吧？哦，是的。所以在 BBC 版本里，大卫·布伦特 (David Brent) 有个朋友叫克里斯·芬奇 (Chris Finch)。他们叫他芬奇。他是英国版里的托德·帕克。基本上这只是一种单方面的最好
friendship and if you can believe Chris Finch is worse than Todd Packer. He is worse. If you watch the British show. You think it can't get worse than Todd Packer. If you're looking for that check out the British version. Exactly. Dave said that he was so excited to come in for Todd Packer because they were just like, Dave, do whatever. And he just was like, oh, I got this. I got this. Him and Steve had just done Anchorman as we talked about. So he knew it was just going to be play time.
友谊，如果你能相信的话，克里斯·芬奇比托德·帕克更糟糕。他更糟糕。如果你看英国版的话。你以为不会比托德·帕克更糟了。如果你在找那个，去看看英国版。没错。戴夫说他非常兴奋能来演托德·帕克，因为他们只是说，戴夫，随便演。他就像，哦，我搞得定。我搞得定。他和史蒂夫刚拍完《王牌播音员》，正如我们谈到的。所以他知道这只是玩耍时间。
I asked Dave, I was like, what is something you remember about that first day as Todd Packer? And he said, I remember the writing. I remember reading that script and thinking how fantastic it was. And I thought, when you have writing this good, anything is possible. I can go anywhere because what I have is so solid. And I said, did you improvise any of that? He said, honestly, I can't remember because I remember thinking the writing was so good. He said, if you see things that feel spontaneous, he said, the physicality of Todd Packer is very me.
我问戴夫，我说，你还记得作为托德·帕克的第一天有什么事吗？他说，我记得剧本。我记得读那个剧本，觉得它太棒了。我想，当你有这么好的剧本时，一切皆有可能。我可以去任何地方，因为我所拥有的非常扎实。我说，你即兴发挥了吗？他说，老实说，我不记得了，因为我记得当时觉得剧本太好了。他说，如果你看到感觉很自发的东西，他说，托德·帕克的肢体语言非常像我。
Is him. Is him. Yeah. You know, like all the stuff he does with Michael, the physical stuff, that's just Dave bringing life to Todd Packer. But he really just was just blown away by how good the writing was.
是他。是他。是的。你知道，就像他与迈克尔所做的一切，那些肢体动作，那只是戴夫赋予托德·帕克生命。但他真的被剧本写得有多好所震撼。
I remember when he came in, I was legitimately shocked and stunned. Why? Well, our show had been very quiet. Oh, right, oh, right. He's just a burst of energy. And he was so loud. And so a lot of my reactions to him are real.
我记得他进来时，我真的感到震惊和惊呆了。为什么？好吧，我们的节目一直很安静。哦，对，对。他只是能量的爆发。他太吵了。所以我对他的很多反应都是真实的。
They're like, what? Why are we shouting? What is happening? Because I miss a lot. This is so, wow. Because are we, why are we shouting? What is happening? Because I'm is a lot. This is so wow. Because I'm 75. I'm Jennifer Fisher. Why are you being so loud? I asked Dave, because Michael has a line where he says that Todd Packer is his BFF, best friend forever. I saw that. Yeah. And I said, Dave, how does Michael, like how is he best friends with Todd Packer? He said something I thought was so sweet actually
它们就像，什么？我们为什么要大喊大叫？发生了什么？因为我错过了很多。这太，哇。因为我们，我们为什么要大喊大叫？发生了什么？因为我错过了很多。这太哇了。因为我75岁了。我是珍娜·费舍尔。你为什么要这么大声？我问戴夫，因为迈克尔有一句台词说托德·帕克是他的 BFF，永远最好的朋友。我看到了。是的。我说，戴夫，迈克尔怎么会……他怎么会和托德·帕克是最好的朋友？他说了一些我觉得实际上很甜的话
and just insightful into Michael. He said, oh, Angela, he said, Michael is so innocent and naive, he's almost childlike. He doesn't get a lot of what Todd Packer is. And how- That's such a good observation. Yeah, he's like a little brother looking up to someone. Yeah.
而且对迈克尔很有洞察力。他说，哦，安吉拉，他说，迈克尔是如此天真和幼稚，他几乎像个孩子。他根本不明白托德·帕克是什么样的人。而且怎么——那是一个很好的观察。是的，他就像一个小弟弟仰望着某人。是的。
And maybe somewhere down the road, he'll see how inappropriate. But he's just in this childlike, enamored phase. Oh, I love that, Dave Keckner. OK. Now it's time to talk about that famous Jim talking head with the phrase, what has two thumbs and hates Todd Packer?
也许在未来的某个时候，他会看到这是多么不合适。但他只是处于这种孩子气的、着迷的阶段。哦，我喜欢那个，戴夫·科克纳。好的。现在是时候谈谈那个著名的吉姆“谈话头”片段了，台词是：“什么东西有两个拇指，讨厌托德·帕克？”
This guy. All right, that joke of like, what has two thumbs and likes blank? And also the very famous line from this episode, that's what she said. Those are not original jokes. We did not make those up. BJ Novak did not write them.
“这家伙。”好吧，那个笑话，比如“什么东西有两个拇指，喜欢某某？”还有这一集里非常著名的台词，“那是她说的”(That's what she said)。那些不是原创笑话。我们没有编造它们。BJ·诺瓦克没有写它们。
BJ said those are things that he just heard in college as a college student and he kind of dusted them off and brought them back to this episode and then they took off. I mean especially that's what she said. I mean well that makes sense because Todd Packer is sort of like a bratty frat guy right? Yes, yes and that's what she said had actually been on SNL. Chevy Chase had a bit where he said it was It was in Wayne's world. But the origin of that joke is a British joke, but the phrase isn't that's what she said. What is it?
BJ说这些话是他还在大学时听到的，他把它们翻出来用在了这一集里，结果就火了。我是说，特别是那句“那是她说的”。我的意思是，这很有道理，因为托德·帕克就像个讨厌的兄弟会男生，对吧？是的，是的，而且“那是她说的”其实在《周六夜现场》里出现过。切维·切斯有个桥段说过，它出现在《韦恩的世界》里。但这个笑话的起源其实是个英国笑话，不过原话不是“那是她说的”。那是什么？
The phrase is, as the actress said to the bishop. Did you like my- That just rolls off the tongue. Yes. But it dwindled in popularity. It was kind of no longer in use until Ricky Gervais brought it back. He used to start saying it. He used to say, as the actress said to the bishop, but it never quite was the same as that's what she said. Okay, this is really off topic, but you know I'm going to have a she shed for myself. I'm making a home office. Oh, I do. It's all you talk about. I know, I know.
原话是，“正如女演员对主教所说的那样”。你喜欢我的——那真是朗朗上口。是的。但它逐渐不再流行了。直到瑞奇·热维斯把它带回来，它才不再被使用。他过去常开始说它。他过去常说，“正如女演员对主教所说的那样”，但这从来没有像“那是她说的”那样效果好。好吧，这真的跑题了，但你知道我要给自己弄个“她的小屋”吗。我正在建一个家庭办公室。哦，我知道。你整天都在说这个。我知道，我知道。
I'm like constantly online and on Pinterest looking at little sheds that I can make into a home office and I've started the process. But I posted a photo of me with a shed and a fan wrote in, please call your shed your that's what she shed. Oh, you have to. I know. Someone start needle pointing a pillow right now, please.
我一直在网上和Pinterest上浏览我可以改造成家庭办公室的小屋，我已经开始了。但我发了一张我和小屋的照片，有个粉丝写信说，请把你的小屋叫作“那是她的小屋”。哦，你一定要这么做。我知道。有人现在就开始绣个枕头吧，拜托。
I'll do it, I like to needle point. Will you needle point me at that's what she shed? Okay. That's what she said. Okay. Oh, 100%. Here's another cultural reference from this episode. When Ryan takes Todd Packer down to the parking lot, yeah, to drive him somewhere because of his DUI's, he has a W L hung. Oh, yes. Right. Yes. I have this on a card. Of course, Todd Packer wants everyone to think says, well, hung, but Ryan says, oh, are you a big fan of William Hung? Do the millennials out there know who William Hung is? Do they get this joke?
我来做，我喜欢刺绣。你会帮我绣“那是她的小屋”吗？好的。那是她说的。好的。哦，百分之百。这是这一集的另一个文化梗。当瑞安带托德·帕克去停车场时，是的，因为他的酒驾记录要开车送他去某处，他有一个威廉·洪。哦，是的。对吧。是的。我有一张卡片上有这个。当然，托德·帕克想让每个人都以为上面写的是“很强壮”，但瑞安说，哦，你是威廉·洪的超级粉丝吗？外面的千禧一代知道威廉·洪是谁吗？他们懂这个梗吗？
I wonder, because this was a very like. Topical of the time kind of joke. Yes. So William Hung was an old American Idol reference. He was a contestant and he gave this horrible, yet very committed rendition of Ricky Martin's She Bangs. Yes, season three. And like the judges could barely hold it together.
我很好奇，因为这在当时是一个非常时髦的梗。是的。所以威廉·洪是一个老掉牙的《美国偶像》梗。他是一名参赛者，他用一种糟糕但非常投入的方式演唱了瑞奇·马丁的《She Bangs》。是的，第三季。评委们几乎都快憋不住笑了。
Bless his heart. It was so pure, so honest. He was like an engineering student. His secret passion in life was a sing. Well, this was before social media, and yet this went quote unquote viral. This video of him auditioning. And he became a huge sensation. He went on tour. Yeah, I think he had his own version of like a TED talk about success, but you can still find it, cause I watched it last night. I did too.
愿上帝保佑他。他太纯真、太诚实了。他当时是个工程系学生。他人生中秘密的激情是唱歌。好吧，这还是在社交媒体出现之前，但这却“走红”了。他试镜的视频。他成了一个巨大的轰动人物。他去巡演了。是的，我想他还有自己版本的关于成功的TED演讲，但你仍然可以找到它，因为我昨晚看了。我也看了。
William Hung. I had to look it up because when I watched this episode, it brought up the memory of that. Also, can we just mention that Todd Packer drives a red convertible Corvette? I mean, buddy. Yeah, I think it was supposed to be a Mustang and they couldn't get one.
威廉·洪。我不得不去查了一下，因为当我看这一集时，它勾起了我对那件事的回忆。另外，我们能提一下托德·帕克开的是一辆红色敞篷科尔维特吗？我是说，伙计。是的，我想它原本应该是辆野马，但他们没弄到。
And so it got changed to a Corvette. Well, it's perfect. It is pretty perfect. Also, in this episode, we learned that Pam's mom is coming into the office and little Pam just keeps sneaking looks at the door. I know. It's so cute. Pam loves her mom.
所以它被换成了科尔维特。嗯，这很完美。确实很完美。另外，在这一集中，我们得知帕姆的妈妈要来办公室了，小帕姆一直偷偷往门口看。我知道。太可爱了。帕姆爱她的妈妈。
This is going to seem like I'm being snarky to Pam's mom. Hear me out. Okay. Well, I'm already feeling defensive. Okay. Pam loves her mom. Pam's mom says, oh, is this your area? I'm like, what, has she never been to the office in three years?
这看起来好像我在对帕姆的妈妈刻薄。听我说完。好吧，我已经感到防御了。好吧。帕姆爱她的妈妈。帕姆的妈妈说，哦，这是你的工作区吗？我在想，什么，她三年都没来过办公室吗？
Three years you've been working at Dunder Mifflin, your mom's never stopped by. It's making me sad. Okay. I'm just saying. I just had a moment. I'm like, why is she so surprised to see Pam's desk? Wow. You are angry.
你在邓德·米夫林工作三年了，你妈妈从来没来过。这让我很难过。好吧。我只是说说。我刚才突然想到。我在想，为什么她看到帕姆的桌子这么惊讶？哇。你很生气。
That's a really good point. I mean, she lives in town. I have a bunch of timecode things too. Oh, timecode us, Angela. Okay, at five minutes, 15 seconds, you guys, there is a fantastic shot of Michael's desk when he's talking to Toby. And I'll tell you what all you see on his desk. You see a mini billiards table. You see like the silver ball clacky thingy. Yes, whoever wants
这是一个很好的观点。我是说，她住在城里。我也有很多时间码的东西。哦，给我们报一下时间码，安吉拉。好的，在5分15秒，伙计们，当迈克尔和托比说话时，有一个迈克尔桌子的精彩镜头。我来告诉你你在他桌子上看到了什么。你看到了一个迷你台球桌。你看到了那个银色的撞球摆件。是的，谁会想要
that on their desk. I don't know. What is that for? I've always wondered. It's probably some kind of Zen thing. I guess. Jenna you see his Dundee. Oh yes there's a great shot of his Dundee and then what looks like is a green magic eight ball and in this scene at the top of the scene, Michael is holding a giant pencil in his hand. Oh, yeah. I mean, that's a little guy. Loves the Spencer's gifts.
那个在桌子上。我不知道。那是干什么用的？我一直很好奇。它可能是一种禅意的东西。我猜。珍娜，你看到了他的邓迪奖。哦，是的，有一个他邓迪奖的特写，然后看起来像是一个绿色的魔法八号球，在这一幕的开头，迈克尔手里拿着一支巨大的铅笔。哦，是的。我是说，那是个小家伙。喜欢斯宾塞礼品店。
He loves the Spencer's. It's his favorite store. But can you imagine Toby like wants to have a serious conversation with him and Michael is holding an oversized pencil throughout the conversation. Yes. So that I thought was just a great, great screen grab if you want to see all the things on Michael's desk.
他喜欢斯宾塞。那是他最喜欢的店。但你能想象托比想和他进行严肃谈话，而迈克尔在谈话过程中一直拿着一支超大铅笔吗。是的。所以我认为如果你想看迈克尔桌子上的所有东西，那是一个非常非常棒的截图。
Okay. And what's next? I have another Dave Keckner story. Oh, great. Is this another one of the stories you didn't record on your phone last night? Yes, Jenna, it is. All right. Thank you. Thank you very much. Let's hear it. When Dave got the call that they wanted him to come in
好的。接下来是什么？我还有另一个戴夫·科克纳的故事。哦，太棒了。这是你昨晚没在手机上录的那些故事中的另一个吗？是的，珍娜，就是。好吧。谢谢。非常感谢。让我们听听。当戴夫接到电话说他们想让他来
for Todd Packer, guess where he was? Where? He was in Canada filming Snakes on a Plane. No. Oh my gosh. It just made me laugh. He was like, yeah, I got the call. I was filming Snakes on a Plane.
演托德·帕克时，猜猜他在哪？在哪？他在加拿大拍《航班蛇患》。不。哦，天哪。这让我笑了。他说，是的，我接到了电话。我当时正在拍《航班蛇患》。
Well, I do know that they had to really manipulate the schedule in order to make it work with him. Yeah, because he was filming Snakes on a Plane. Yeah, we got him for one day. We had to film all of the Todd Packer stuff in one day. So he could then go back to Canada and be in Snakes on a Plane. One of my favorite scenes in this episode, Angela.
嗯，我知道他们为了配合他的档期确实做了很大的调整。是的，因为他在拍《航班蛇患》。是的，我们只争取到他一天的时间。我们必须在一天内拍完所有托德·帕克的戏份。这样他才能回加拿大继续拍《航班蛇患》。安吉拉，这是这一集中我最喜欢的场景之一。
Yes. Is when, I have two, they both involve Toby. Oh yeah. Okay, the first is when Toby reveals he has to do a review of the sexual harassment policy. One thing I noticed was I felt like Toby was super excited that he was gonna get to run something for a change and that Michael had no choice.
是的。是当，我有两个，都和托比有关。哦，是的。好的，第一个是当托比透露他必须对性骚扰政策进行审查时。我注意到的一件事是，我觉得托比超级兴奋，因为他终于可以负责某件事了，而且迈克尔别无选择。
I don't know, I just watched the scene a couple times and I felt like I could see this little like happy glint in Paul's eye as he was explaining to Michael that he was going to do this, period. But I also noticed that Toby's presentation happens in the bullpen. Yes. It does not happen in the conference room.
我不知道，我把那个场景看了几遍，我觉得我能看到保罗眼里闪过一丝快乐的光芒，当他向迈克尔解释他要负责这件事时，句号。但我还注意到托比的演讲是在办公区进行的。是的。不是在会议室。
And if I remember correctly, it is because we decided that Michael would allow him to have his presentation, but not in the conference room. Not in his space. Yeah, under no circumstances. Maybe I just made that up in my own head. Maybe it's true. The other thing that was interesting to me that we'd never seen before is Toby does a
如果我没记错的话，这是因为我们决定迈克尔会允许他进行演讲，但不能在会议室。不能在他的地盘。是的，绝对不行。也许是我自己脑补的。也许是真的。另一件让我觉得有趣的事情是，我们以前从未见过，托比在
talking head in front of the vending machine in the break room. Oh. And that is not where our talking heads ever are. They're always in the conference room. Toby is clearly, ever since he got thrown out of the conference room, has not been invited back into the conference room. I watched the deleted scenes for this, and there is a runner of Michael talking heads where he's just talking about how much he hates Toby in different ways.
休息室的自动售货机前做了一个采访。哦。那不是我们采访通常进行的地方。它们总是在会议室。托比显然自从被赶出会议室后，就再也没被邀请回去过。我看了这一集的删减片段，里面有一连串迈克尔的采访，他一直在用各种方式表达他有多讨厌托比。
Oh my gosh. It's so good. I have to say, for anybody out there who is wishing there was more Office, or wishing you could watch more of the Office, you actually can. It is the deleted scenes. I have been enjoying them so much. So really, look for them, because just these runner
哦，天哪。太棒了。我必须说，对于任何希望有更多《办公室》内容，或者希望看更多《办公室》的人来说，你们其实可以看。那就是删减片段。我一直很享受它们。所以一定要去找来看看，因为仅仅是这些
of talking heads from Michael were wonderful. Yeah, I saw some that were pretty amazing. And I wonder out there if the webisodes are available. Oh yeah, you guys won an Emmy award for your webisodes. I know, we won an Emmy. I remember that. For the accountants. Yeah.
迈克尔的采访片段就非常精彩。是的，我看到了一些非常棒的。我很好奇网剧集是否还能找到。哦，是的，你们为网剧集赢得了艾美奖。我知道，我们赢得了艾美奖。我记得。为了会计师系列。是的。
I really want some more Pop-Tart. I have it sitting next to me, but I'm afraid it's going to be really loud. We can take a Pop-Tart break if you need to. Angela, you want us to take a break so you can have some Pop-Tart? Is this how you talk to your kids, Jenna? Baby, you want to have some Pop-Tart? Yes, I want to have Pop-Tart. All right, guys, we're going to take a break so Angela can have some pop tart? Is this how you talk to your kids, Jenna? Baby, you wanna have some pop tart? Yes, I wanna have pop tart. All right, guys, we're gonna take a break
我真的很想再吃点Pop-Tart。它就在我旁边，但我怕声音会很大。如果你需要的话，我们可以休息一下吃Pop-Tart。安吉拉，你想让我们休息一下让你吃Pop-Tart吗？珍娜，你平时是这样和你孩子说话的吗？宝贝，你想吃Pop-Tart吗？是的，我想吃Pop-Tart。好吧，伙计们，我们要休息一下，让安吉拉吃Pop-Tart？珍娜，你平时是这样和你孩子说话的吗？宝贝，你想吃Pop-Tart吗？是的，我想吃Pop-Tart。好吧，伙计们，我们要休息一下
so Angela can have more of her pop tart. Tell me, can you hear me eating this pop tart? One second. Yeah, it's gross. Oh, why, it's not gross, it's a pop tart. No one wants to listen to someone chew and swallow. That is maybe something she said. All right, we're going to break. Welcome back everybody. All right, this is totally off topic, but in preparing for this episode,
让安吉拉吃她的Pop-Tart。告诉我，你能听到我吃Pop-Tart的声音吗？等一下。是的，很恶心。哦，为什么，这不恶心，这是Pop-Tart。没人想听别人咀嚼和吞咽的声音。那也许是她说过的话。好吧，我们要休息了。欢迎回来，各位。好吧，这完全跑题了，但在准备这一集时，
I like to go back and look at some of the old photos that I have and sort of, it helps me remember things. As you know, I'm a hoarder. I have multiple bins of photos. I found pictures, Jenna, from my first red carpet. It was with you. I was your plus one. I will never forget this. You know what it was called?
我喜欢回去看看我的一些旧照片，这有助于我回忆事情。如你所知，我是个囤积狂。我有好几个装照片的箱子。珍娜，我找到了我第一次走红毯的照片。是和你一起。我是你的随行人员。我永远不会忘记这个。你知道它叫什么吗？
Pause for style. Not pause button, guys, pause. Like a dog, like a P-A-W-S. Pause for style. Not pause button guys pause like a dog like a P-A-W-S pause for style. Yes it was a runway show where celebrities walked a catwalk with their dogs and the dogs were wearing the fashion. So the celebrities were wearing whatever they showed up in and the dogs were dressed in outfits. It was kind of a hot mess. And the money went to the Humane Society. That's why we went. Yes.
“爪子时尚秀”。不是暂停键，伙计们，是爪子。像狗一样的爪子。爪子时尚秀。不是暂停键，伙计们，是爪子，像狗一样的爪子，爪子时尚秀。是的，那是一场时装秀，名人们带着他们的狗走猫步，狗穿着时尚服装。所以名人们穿着他们随便穿来的衣服，而狗穿着精心设计的服装。那简直是一团糟。钱都捐给了人道协会。这就是我们去的原因。是的。
You were invited with your dog. Invited to bring my dog, Wesley. And Angela, this was your first red carpet. We talked in the Dundee's episode about how I walked the red carpet for 40-year-old Virgin. And I somehow just didn't do it. You skipped it. I don't think it was intentional. I think I just didn't know. I think I just went inside and got my popcorn. But for pause for style,
你被邀请带着你的狗。被邀请带上我的狗，韦斯利。安吉拉，这是你的第一次红毯。我们在《邓迪奖》那一集谈过我是怎么为《四十岁的老处男》走红毯的。我不知怎么就没走。你错过了。我不认为是有意的。我想我只是不知道。我想我只是走进去拿了我的爆米花。但对于“爪子时尚秀”，
you did walk the red carpet. Yeah, I wanted to pick the biggest event possible to my first red carpet. For your coming out. I said, I mean, it's almost like my character. Do you know how many photographers there are? Two. Angela, over here., Angela over here. It was like art, like life recreating art or whatever. Was that saying? Life intimidating, or no, I'm tired. I just spit out my coffee. You said life intimidating art. I am tired, you guys.
你确实走了红毯。是的，我想为我的第一次红毯选择尽可能大的活动。为了你的首次亮相。我说，我是说，这几乎就像我的角色。你知道有多少摄影师吗？两个。安吉拉，看这边，安吉拉，看这边。这就像艺术，就像生活重现艺术还是什么的。那句话怎么说来着？生活恐吓艺术，或者不，我累了。我刚才把咖啡喷出来了。你说的是生活恐吓艺术。我累了，伙计们。
I am so tired. Art imitating life. That's what I'm trying to say. Not life intimidating art. Oh, good Lord. Anyway, so here we are at Paws for Style. The big name was Paula Abdul. With her two or three dogs she had.
我太累了。艺术模仿生活。这就是我想说的。不是生活恐吓艺术。哦，天哪。总之，我们就在“爪子时尚秀”现场。大牌是宝拉·阿巴杜。带着她的两三只狗。
Like three little dogs in outfits. I remember meeting her out by the red carpet. I remember Wesley and her dogs, they all smelled each other as they do. She was very nice. Very nice. I have great photos from this night. I as they do. She was very nice. Very nice. I have great photos from this night. I mean, spectacular.
就像三只穿着衣服的小狗。我记得在红毯边见到她。我记得韦斯利和她的狗，它们像往常一样互相闻了闻。她非常友善。非常友善。我那天晚上拍了很棒的照片。我像往常一样。她非常友善。非常友善。我那天晚上拍了很棒的照片。我是说，太壮观了。
I did my own hair and makeup. This is before I discovered a flat iron. So it's just frizzy guys. It's just frizzy down and straight. I bought a tank top at Target. And I bought one at the Gap and I layered them. I layered my tank tops. They're both turquoise.
我自己做的头发和化妆。这是在我发现直发夹板之前。所以头发很毛躁，伙计们。就是那种毛躁的直发。我在塔吉特买了一件背心。又在盖普买了一件，然后我把它们叠穿了。我叠穿了我的背心。它们都是绿松石色的。
Why did I layer two turquoise tank tops? And then I bought some white jeans at Target. And this is what I wore. Now I'm gonna say something. You always really do look good in turquoise, Angela. Thank you. It's a great color on you. So I think in that way, you styled yourself well.
我为什么要叠穿两件绿松石色的背心？然后我在塔吉特买了一些白色的牛仔裤。这就是我穿的。现在我要说一件事。安吉拉，你穿绿松石色真的很好看。谢谢。这颜色很适合你。所以我认为在那方面，你把自己打扮得很好。
Thank you. I think you can tell, cause you texted me the photo of you on the red carpet. I think you can tell that, how can I say this, that you'd never done a red carpet? I mean, you look a little bit stiff. How can I say this? I love how delicately you're trying to put this.
谢谢。我想你能看出来，因为你给我发了你在红毯上的照片。我想你能看出来，我该怎么说呢，你以前从没走过红毯？我是说，你看上去有点僵硬。我该怎么说呢？我喜欢你试图委婉表达的样子。
Jenna, it's like, you know how if you stand and you put your hands on your hip? Yeah. What if you decided to stand, but do your legs spread way too far apart? Yeah. And then instead of putting your hands on your hip and your five one guys, your five one,
珍娜，就像，你知道如果你站着，把手放在臀部上？是的。如果你决定站着，但把双腿分得太开会怎样？是的。然后你没有把手放在臀部上，而且你们只有五英尺一英寸，伙计们，你们只有五英尺一英寸，
you decide to put them on your mid thigh? Yeah, kind of like above your legs. Almost like you're doing a squat. Yeah. Like, and then you smiled a camera. That's what I did. That's what she did. Yeah, that's what I did. Why did I stand like that? Listen, you guys, we didn't know anything about red carpets. We didn't know what the hell we were doing. We didn't have anyone advising us. Well, do you remember Angela, after this event, we saw the pictures and we decided we needed to get better at this? Yeah. Oh, yeah. And then do you remember that I had read somewhere that the reason that Mary-Kate and Ashley Olsen always look so cute on the
你决定把它们放在大腿中部？是的，就像在腿上方。几乎就像你在做深蹲。是的。然后你对着镜头微笑。我就是这么做的。那是她做的。是的，我就是这么做的。我为什么要那样站着？听着，伙计们，我们对红毯一无所知。我们根本不知道自己在干什么。没有人给我们建议。好吧，安吉拉，你还记得这次活动后，我们看到照片，决定我们需要在这方面做得更好吗？是的。哦，是的。然后你还记得我曾在某处读到过，玛丽-凯特和阿什莉·奥尔森在红毯上总是看起来那么可爱的秘诀是，她们在摄影师拍照时说“梅干”这个词吗。这个想法是它能让你看起来非常嘟嘴和性感。所以我们在下一次红毯上决定我们要一直说“梅干”。所以就像梅干，梅干，梅干。那是我存在的最糟糕的照片。我看起来便秘了。那真是个糟糕的主意。我以为我看起来只是生气。我看起来像需要上厕所。我看起来很痛苦。哦，天哪，安吉拉，回想我们所有的好主意。我们的好主意。我觉得公平地说，这些都是你的主意。
red carpet is because they say the word prune while the photographers are taking their photograph. The idea is that it makes you look like really like pouty and sexy. So we decided at our next red carpet that we were going to say prune the whole time. So it was like prune, prune, prune. They're the worst photos of me like that exist. I look constipated. It was such a horrible idea. I thought I just looked angry. I looked like I need to poop. That's what I just look miserable. Oh, my gosh, Angela, I think back on all of our bright ideas. Our bright ideas. I think it's fair to say these are all your ideas.
为什么你会跟着我做？我不知道。我知道你很有说服力。我不知道。我只是，你很有说服力。我不知道。我当时就像，好吧，我会走过去，假装大笑，当我走向人们时。好的，我会说梅干，好的。
Why did you go along with them? I don't know. I know you're very persuasive. I don't know. I just't, you're very persuasive. I don't know. I just was like, okay, I'll walk up and pretend to fake laugh as I walk up to people. Okay, I'll say prune, okay.
好吧，我们应该回到这一集了。好的，我们开始吧。哦，我有一个小道消息。太棒了，你的小道消息是什么？我觉得我在16分01秒看到约翰·卡拉辛斯基快要笑场了。所以迈克尔不能再说“那是她说的”了。
All right, what should we, we should get back to this episode. Okay, let's do it. Oh, I have a tidbit. Great, what's your tidbit? I think I see John Krasinski about to break at 16 minutes, one second. So Michael cannot say that's what she said anymore.
是的，他从办公室出来，做了一个隆重的宣布，他要从喜剧界退休了。是的，他不会再说，你知道，吉姆说，甚至连“那是她说的”也不说了。他说，不。我记得拍摄这一幕。我也记得拍摄这一幕。当史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔笑场时，他说“那是她说的”，他的笑声是那么巨大、轻快且具有感染力。是的。
Yes, he comes out of his office, he makes a grand announcement, he's retiring from comedy. Yes, and he's not going to say, you know, Jim is like, not even that's what she said. And he's like, Nope, I remember filming this scene. I remember filming this too. And Steve, as Michael, when he breaks, and he goes, that's what she said, his laugh is so huge and giddy and contagious. Yes.
是的，他走出办公室，郑重宣布他要退出喜剧界。没错，他甚至没说那句经典的“她也这么说”。他说，不，我记得拍这一幕的时候。我也记得拍这一幕。当史蒂夫饰演的迈克尔忍不住笑场，说出“她也这么说”时，他的笑声是那么大、那么兴奋，极具感染力。没错。
And he's so happy and pleased with himself that we literally almost started to all laugh ourselves. And you catch it in John for just a second. Really? Yeah, do you wanna see? Well, also as Steve is leaving and he's being pushed back into his office by Jan and the lawyer,
他对自己感到非常高兴和满意，以至于我们差点真的笑出声来。你可以在约翰脸上捕捉到那一瞬间。真的吗？是啊，你想看吗？还有，当史蒂夫离开时，他被简和律师推回办公室，
he blows a kiss. He's so happy. But look at John's face. It's 16 minutes, one second. Sam, can you pull that up? That include that's what she said? Yes. Wow, that is really hard.
他送了一个飞吻。他太高兴了。但看看约翰的脸。在16分01秒。山姆，你能调出来吗？那包括“她如是说”吗？是的。哇，那真的很难。
You really think you can go all day long? Well, you always left me satisfied and smiling, so. That's what she said! Michael, Michael, come on. Michael, please. Look at John, look at John. Do you see how he puts his hand in front of his face? For sure. That's what he would do when he was starting to laugh.
你真的认为你能坚持一整天吗？嗯，你总是让我感到满足和微笑，所以。那是她如是说！迈克尔，迈克尔，拜托。迈克尔，求你了。看约翰，看约翰。你看到他怎么把手放在脸前了吗？肯定的。当他开始笑的时候，他就会那样做。
Yes, for sure. Yeah. That, I mean, and that is just Steve, because he is a master. He is such a master at like any kind of like big emotional moment. We've talked about how it's really hard to fake laugh. Yeah.
是的，肯定的。那是，我的意思是，那完全是史蒂夫，因为他是一位大师。他在处理任何那种重大的情感时刻时都是一位大师。我们谈过假笑有多难。
It's harder than fake crying. Oh, for sure. Steve is one of the best at the fake laugh. For sure. So we skipped something that I definitely wanna go back to. Okay, what? So we skipped something that I definitely want to go back to. OK, what?
这比假哭更难。哦，肯定的。史蒂夫是假笑方面最出色的人之一。肯定的。所以我们跳过了一些我绝对想回去讲的内容。好的，什么？所以我们跳过了一些我绝对想回去讲的内容。好的，什么？
When Michael crashes Toby's presentation and he walks in with the blow-up doll, do you remember the days and days of those guys trying to figure out which blow-up doll should be the blow-up doll? Oh, yeah. So it was like, should she have on an outfit? Should she be wearing underwear? Should she be wearing a bikini?
当迈克尔闯入托比的演讲，带着充气娃娃走进来时，你还记得那些家伙花了好几天时间来决定哪个充气娃娃应该作为那个充气娃娃吗？哦，是的。当时就像，她应该穿一套衣服吗？她应该穿内衣吗？她应该穿比基尼吗？
There had a variety of blow-up dolls. This is a weird thing about working on a television show or in a movie or anything, are the really just very matter of fact discussions about odd things. I remember seeing our props master and Greg and I think it must have been BJ and Ken Quapus but like there was a group of people looking at different blow-up dolls and having a very matter-of-fact discussion
他们有各种各样的充气娃娃。这是在电视节目或电影中工作的一个奇怪之处，就是对奇怪的事情进行非常客观的讨论。我记得看到我们的道具师和格雷格，我想一定是BJ和肯·夸普斯，但有一群人在看不同的充气娃娃，并进行非常客观的讨论，
about what is funniest. There was one that had a more open mouth. I remember that one that was it we nixed that one. That one was so off-putting. Yeah. But the other thing too is we'd walk on set and you know backstage we would have like props and things and I remember walking past like five blow-up dolls every morning for like a week. It's like what is our life? And then Michael has a lot of comedy with that blow-up doll. I love that part when we're jumping around here but when Pam's mom does finally come in and Michael walks out of his office and like chucks it out the door in like a grandiose statement.
讨论哪个最有趣。有一个嘴巴张得比较大。我记得那个，我们否决了那个。那个太让人反感了。是的。但另一件事是，我们会走进片场，你知道在后台我们会有道具之类的东西，我记得有一周每天早上我都会经过五个充气娃娃。这算什么生活？然后迈克尔和那个充气娃娃有很多喜剧互动。我喜欢我们跳来跳去的那部分，但当帕姆的妈妈终于进来，迈克尔走出办公室，像发表宏大声明一样把它扔出门外时。
But also in the scene with Jan, it's hiding up on top of his credenza. And Jim has this talking head with the blow-up doll. So the blow-up doll got a lot of play in this episode. It was very important that we picked the right one. Yeah. Bit of a character. The blow-up doll was going to of play in this episode. It was very important that we picked the right one. Yeah. Bit of a character. The blow-up doll was going to be featured, and those conversations were warranted.
但在与简的场景中，它藏在他的餐具柜上。吉姆和充气娃娃有一个谈话头。所以充气娃娃在这个剧集中有很多戏份。选择正确的那个非常重要。是的。有点像个角色。充气娃娃将成为主角，这些讨论是合理的。
OK. Something else I want to mention, unrelated to the blow-up doll. When Michael takes over the sexual harassment seminar, there is a great deleted scene where Michael goes on this runner. Did you see it? No. Where he says it's about him and Pam.
好的。我想提另一件事，与充气娃娃无关。当迈克尔接管性骚扰研讨会时，有一个很棒的删减片段，迈克尔进行了这段独白。你看到了吗？没有。他说这是关于他和帕姆的。
And I remember shooting the scene, and I couldn't get through it. Not the bathtub thing. No, not the bathtub thing. This was a different runner where Michael says, all right, take for example, Pam and I are dating. And I say that would never happen. He goes, no, it's happening. Pam and I are dating.
我记得拍摄那个场景时，我无法演下去。不是浴缸那件事。不，不是浴缸那件事。这是另一个独白，迈克尔说，好吧，举个例子，帕姆和我在约会。我说那永远不会发生。他说，不，正在发生。帕姆和我在约会。
And I'm like, I'm engaged. He's like, Roy died. And I'm like, even still. And he's like, then I would kill you. He's the, now Roy and Pam are both dead look at what sexual harassment some of our gods I did see that very funny thing actually did see that in a montage that is hilarious yes and then just Michael just like really pushing this like hypothetical situation where he and Pam are dating and that comes up every once in a while
我说我订婚了。他说，罗伊死了。我说，即使这样也不行。他说，那我就杀了你。他是，现在罗伊和帕姆都死了，看看这些性骚扰研讨会，天哪，我确实看到了那个非常有趣的片段，实际上是在蒙太奇里看到的，那太搞笑了，是的，然后迈克尔真的在推销这种他和帕姆约会的假设情况，这种情况偶尔会出现
situation where he and Pam are dating. And that comes up every once in a while. Every once in a while, there's a little thing where Pam has to deal with Michael's hypothetical that there's a world where maybe they're dating. There was clearly a time he had a crush on you. I guess so. And he finally just gave up. And what about in that same scene,
他和帕姆约会的假设情况。这种情况偶尔会出现。偶尔，帕姆不得不处理迈克尔的假设，即可能存在一个他们正在约会的世界。很明显，他曾经暗恋过你。我想是吧。他终于放弃了。那么在同一个场景中呢，
Phyllis's line where she asks if you have to disclose one night stands. They talk about you have to report a relationship to HR and she goes, all relationships, even a one night stand. Yes, what is she, is she talking about a previous one night stand or a future one night stand? I don't know, but John's look to camera as Jim
菲利斯的台词，她问你是否必须披露一夜情。他们谈到你必须向人力资源部报告一段关系，她说，所有关系，甚至是一夜情。是的，她是，她在谈论之前的一夜情还是未来的一夜情？我不知道，但约翰作为吉姆看向镜头的眼神
when she says that is so gold. That is classic Jim look to camera. Let's talk about my other favorite Toby scene. What's that? At the end of Toby's seminar, he says, if you have any questions, you can come speak to me. And Dwight goes to him and they have that big long conversation where Dwight is basically asking about female anatomy and sex.
当她说那句话时，真是太经典了。那是典型的吉姆看向镜头的眼神。让我们谈谈我另一个最喜欢的托比场景。是什么？在托比研讨会的最后，他说，如果你有任何问题，你可以来找我。德怀特去找他，他们进行了那段很长的对话，德怀特基本上是在问关于女性解剖结构和性的问题。
Yeah, it starts around 12 minutes. I have it on a card. A lot of people asked about that scene. Was it scripted? Was it improvised? So when Dwight asks, where is the clitoris? That is where the scene was supposed to end. So everything after that, those were all Reign's improvisations and they shot that scene for
是的，大约在12分钟左右开始。我把它写在卡片上了。很多人问过那个场景。是剧本写的吗？还是即兴创作的？所以当德怀特问，阴蒂在哪里？那是场景本该结束的地方。所以在那之后的一切，都是雷恩的即兴创作，他们拍摄那个场景拍了
about two hours. They shot it for so long. And also, Paul is Toby was improvising as well. Yes. And I thought he had such a great line when he was like, well, you know, when you're both more comfortable, you know, he has this great line. And I wrote, who is Dwight asking the advice for?
大约两个小时。他们拍了很久。而且，保罗作为托比也在即兴发挥。是的。我觉得他有一句很棒的台词，他说，嗯，你知道，当你们都更舒服的时候，你知道，他有这句很棒的台词。我写道，德怀特是在向谁寻求建议？
Right? Is this the beginning of Dwight and Angela? I wondered the same thing. And people pointed this out. Dwight seems very comfortable I wondered the same thing. And people pointed this out. Dwight seems very comfortable around women in Hot Girl. He doesn't seem to have any of these hangups necessarily. And then now suddenly in this episode, he's revealing maybe the truth, which
对吧？这是德怀特和安吉拉的开始吗？我也想过同样的问题。人们指出了这一点。德怀特在《辣妹》中看起来对女性非常自在。他似乎不一定有任何这些顾虑。然后现在突然在这一集中，他揭示了真相，也许是
is that he doesn't know so many things about women. Well, I also think that he might actually have a woman, finally, who might be interested in doing those things with him. Perhaps. And he's realized he doesn't have the skill set for it. Ah, ah, I think that's what it is. Oh, Angela. What? This is the first episode where we finally see the real outside of the Dunder Mifflin that we will come to know and love. Oh, when Michael goes down to get jokes?
他不知道关于女性的很多事情。嗯，我也认为他可能终于有了一个可能对他做这些事情感兴趣的女人。也许吧。他意识到他没有这方面的技能。啊，啊，我想就是这样。哦，安吉拉。什么？这是我们终于看到邓德·米夫林之外的真实世界的第一个剧集，我们将了解并爱上它。哦，当迈克尔下去拿笑话时？
Yes, when he goes down to meet the warehouse guys. Well, you see it, we see the parking lot. Yeah. When Ryan takes Todd Packer down, but then you really see him come down through the lobby and outside and around the corner. And he's talking to all the warehouse guys. I thought that was so cool.
是的，当他下去见仓库员工时。嗯，你看到了，我们看到了停车场。是的。当瑞安带托德·帕克下去时，但随后你真的看到他穿过大厅，走到外面，绕过拐角。他在和所有的仓库员工交谈。我觉得那太酷了。
I did too. I thought it was great. So the point of that scene, because I was texting with BJ about this, to all the warehouse guys, I thought that was so cool. I did too. I thought it was great. So the point of that scene, because I was texting with BJ about this, the point of that scene was that Michael would go down to ask for jokes and then the guys in the warehouse would actually start sexually harassing Michael. So that's the point. They start commenting on his appearance and his pants and-
我也这么觉得。我觉得那段太棒了。那场戏的重点——因为我当时正和BJ发短信讨论这个——对所有仓库员工来说，我觉得那太酷了。我也这么觉得。我觉得那段太棒了。那场戏的重点——因为我当时正和BJ发短信讨论这个——那场戏的重点在于迈克尔下楼去要笑话，结果仓库里的那些人反而开始对迈克尔进行性骚扰。所以重点就在这儿。他们开始评论他的外表和他的裤子，还有——
Package, his lack of package. Yes, and all that sort of stuff. And yet somehow this does not land on Michael. He learns nothing from being the recipient of harassment. It just, he's just frustrated they didn't give him a good joke. He could use. But then later, all those same warehouse guys are called up to the conference room and they have to watch a sexual harassment training video.
他的包裹，他那没有包裹的部位。没错，诸如此类。然而不知为何，迈克尔完全没意识到这一点。他从遭受骚扰这件事上什么也没学到。他只是因为他们没给他讲个好笑话而感到沮丧。他本可以用得上的。但后来，所有那些仓库员工都被叫到会议室，不得不观看一部性骚扰培训视频。
But did you notice it's all those guys and Kevin? Yes, well here's what I think. I think Kevin is kind of like that teenage kid who if there's any chance he might see someone in a bra, oh, maybe side boob. Oh, he's in that. He's in that. He's the one that does the MILF joke about your mom.
但你注意到了吗？全是那些家伙，还有凯文？是的，嗯，我是这么想的。我觉得凯文就像那种十几岁的孩子，如果有一丁点机会能看到别人穿胸罩，哦，也许是侧面的乳沟，哦，他就会很兴奋。他就是那种人。他就是那个拿你妈妈开“熟女”玩笑的人。
Like, he's kind of like, I feel like the kid who is like excited to maybe see anything go down. Well, I think that sexual harassment video is amazing. We shot that, that's not a real sexual harassment video. Joel wrote in and asked, did the actors in the sexual harassment video know they wrote in and asked, did the actors in the sexual harassment video know they were auditioning for a sitcom or did they think it was just an educational video?
就像，我觉得他就像那种对可能发生的任何事都感到兴奋的孩子。嗯，我觉得那部性骚扰视频太棒了。我们拍了那段，那不是真正的性骚扰视频。乔尔写信来问，性骚扰视频里的演员知道他们是在为情景喜剧试镜，还是以为那只是个教育视频？
That's an awesome question. They knew that they were going to appear on The Office, but they were told to pretend like they were making a real educational video. They did a phenomenal job. Those guest actors were amazing. They were amazing. And we shot that in the actual writers' offices. All right, I found it hilarious that when Michael
这是个很棒的问题。他们知道自己会出现在《办公室》里，但他们被告知要假装是在制作一部真正的教育视频。他们表现得非常出色。那些客串演员太棒了。他们太棒了。而且我们是在真正的编剧办公室里拍摄的。好了，我觉得迈克尔在那个场景里很有趣，当他
is in the scene with Jan and the corporate lawyer, I feel like this is the first time Michael realizes that he's upper management. Oh, and he's so proud. He's so proud. He's so proud of himself, because he's hired James P. Albini, the guy from the bus stop, to be his lawyer.
和简以及公司律师在一起时，我觉得这是迈克尔第一次意识到自己是高层管理人员。哦，他太骄傲了。他太骄傲了。他为自己感到无比自豪，因为他雇佣了詹姆斯·P·阿尔比尼，那个公交车站的人，来当他的律师。
I love that scene. Actually, that's a really great scene to watch if you want to nerd out on the camera work and the way that the camera helps tell the story on the office, because that whole entrance of Michael's lawyer, the way Michael's lawyer looks directly at camera and gives a little plug for his business is pretty great, but the camera work in that scene is really incredible. Also in that scene, Toby, where he's sitting, he's not been invited to sit sort of in the- In the circle. Yeah, he's off against the wall.
我喜欢那个场景。事实上，如果你想钻研摄影技巧以及摄像机如何帮助《办公室》讲述故事，那是一个非常棒的场景，因为迈克尔律师的整个出场，迈克尔律师直视镜头并为他的生意做小广告的方式非常棒，但那场戏的摄影确实令人难以置信。同样在那场戏里，托比，他坐的地方，他没有被邀请坐在那个——在圈子里。是的，他靠在墙边。
It's a great scene to watch, just watch Toby through the whole scene, it's pretty delicious. And Toby has a great snarky moment in that scene because Jan's like, Michael, are you going to have to watch the video again? And he's like, I watched the video. And Toby goes, he talked through most of it. Yes. Toby, Toby throwing him under the bus.
那是一场很棒的戏，只要在整场戏中观察托比，非常有趣。托比在那场戏里有一个很棒的讽刺时刻，因为简说，迈克尔，你还要再看一遍视频吗？他说，我看过视频了。托比说，他看的时候一直在说话。是的。托比，托比把他推向了风口浪尖。
So now we finally have to talk about the scene where Michael stands up to Todd Packer, otherwise known as the boner scene. The boner scene. Todd Packer is making this joke about someone attending a nymphomaniac's convention. Yeah and all the gals are like perfect tins except for this one gal. And he points to Phyllis. And then Kevin says, I like Phyllis. And then Phyllis looks really sad. Oh so sad. So hurt. So hurt and it's awkward. of all, do we need a joke about a nymphomaniac convention? Exactly.
所以现在我们终于要谈谈迈克尔站出来对抗托德·帕克的场景了，也就是所谓的“硬了”场景。“硬了”场景。托德·帕克在讲一个关于有人参加性瘾者大会的笑话。是的，所有的姑娘们都很完美，除了这一个。他指着菲利斯。然后凯文说，我喜欢菲利斯。然后菲利斯看起来非常难过。哦，太难过了。太受伤了。太受伤了，而且很尴尬。首先，我们需要一个关于性瘾者大会的笑话吗？确实。
Todd Packer, thank you very much. And Michael sees that Phyllis is hurt and he says that that was inappropriate. He says something, but then Todd Packer challenges him and he's like, I mean, Kevin, Kevin, you should not say those things about Phyllis. And then he goes on this whole speech about how Phyllis is great and how he loves Phyllis. She's like a grandmother to them. And she says, I mean, Michael, we're the same age. We went to high school together.
托德·帕克，非常感谢你。迈克尔看到菲利斯受伤了，他说那是不恰当的。他说了一些话，但随后托德·帕克挑战他，他说，我是说，凯文，凯文，你不应该那样说菲利斯。然后他发表了一整段演讲，说菲利斯有多棒，他有多爱菲利斯。她就像他们的祖母一样。她说，我是说，迈克尔，我们同岁。我们一起上的高中。
We're in the same high school class. I love that. I love that. And that fact comes back to haunt Michael all the time. She is constantly reminding him in the series that they went to high school together. It's a really sweet scene. And he hugs hugs Phyllis and then he says the only thing he's afraid of is getting a boner. A boner? And then Phyllis' face, her reaction is what made it for me.
我们在同一个高中班级。我喜欢这个。我喜欢这个。而这个事实一直困扰着迈克尔。她在剧集中不断提醒他，他们是一起上高中的。这是一个非常温馨的场景。他拥抱了菲利斯，然后他说他唯一害怕的就是“硬了”。“硬了”？然后菲利斯的脸，她的反应对我来说才是点睛之笔。
It made that whole scene. It really did. It really did. And I think that there was this way where, I don't know, do you think Michael is redeemed in that moment a little bit? Because he stands up for his group a little bit. He does. I think it's definitely the first time he has stood up to Todd Packer. And you can tell because when you see Todd Packer's face, he's like, oh man, they really got to you.
这成就了整个场景。确实如此。确实如此。而且我觉得有一种方式，我不知道，你觉得迈克尔在那一刻得到了一点救赎吗？因为他为他的团队挺身而出了一点点。他确实做到了。我觉得这绝对是他第一次站出来对抗托德·帕克。你可以看出来，因为当你看到托德·帕克的脸时，他就像是，哦伙计，他们真的抓到你了。
And Michael's like, no, I got to them. Like whatever that means. But I think it's the first time he stood up to him. And even though it's a very small way, I think it's that moment once again, where this is our writers trying to give Michael a little bit of a growth moment. What? Angela, this is...
迈克尔说，不，是我抓住了他们。不管那意味着什么。但我认为这是他第一次站出来对抗他。即使是以一种非常微小的方式，我认为这再次证明了我们的编剧试图给迈克尔一点成长的时刻。什么？安吉拉，这是……
You just referred to the boner scene as the scene where the writers give Michael a little bit of a growth moment. Oh no. That's perfect, that's perfect. Okay, now let's talk about the scene with Pam's mom. We said a little bit of a growth moment. Oh, no. That's perfect. That's perfect. Okay, now let's talk about the scene with Pam's mom. We said a little bit about this earlier. Angela, you expressed your disgust that this is her first visit.
你刚才把“硬了”场景称为编剧给迈克尔一点成长时刻的场景。哦，不。太完美了，太完美了。好了，现在让我们谈谈关于帕姆妈妈的场景。我们之前稍微提了一下。安吉拉，你表达了对这是她第一次来访的厌恶。
Okay, I just am saying, like, where have you been, mom? That's all. I get it. I get it. But there is more to say here. Yeah. So first of all, Pam's mom was played by Shannon Cochran. And a lot of people wrote in and said, what the heck is up with Pam's mom?
好吧，我只是想说，妈妈，你都去哪儿了？就是这样。我明白了。我明白了。但这里还有更多要说的。是的。首先，帕姆的妈妈由香农·科克伦饰演。很多人写信问，帕姆的妈妈到底是怎么回事？
Why is she played by one person in this episode and then another person later on in the show? I will tell you, we wanted Shannon Cochran to come back. We cast her as Pam's mom. We intended for her to always play Pam's mom, but then we didn't need Pam's mom for a really long time. Shannon got a theater contract. She was a touring theater actress with, you know, Rain, her and I had a lot to discuss.
为什么她在这一集中由一个人扮演，后来又换成了另一个人？我会告诉你，我们想让香农·科克伦回来。我们选她演帕姆的妈妈。我们本意是让她一直扮演帕姆的妈妈，但后来我们很长一段时间都不需要帕姆的妈妈。香农签了一份戏剧合同。她是一位巡回演出的戏剧演员，你知道，雷恩，她和我有很多要讨论的。
Oh, look at, yes. Theater pedigree. Fancy theater people. That's right. And she wasn't available. And so we had to recast her for those later episodes. And it was a really weird thing because the integrity of our show was so important to us.
哦，看，是的。戏剧血统。高级的戏剧人。没错。她没空。所以我们不得不为后来的剧集重新选角。这是一件非常奇怪的事情，因为我们节目的完整性对我们来说非常重要。
There was this rule for a very long time that we couldn't do any stunt casting. Yeah. I don't know if people know what that means. Yeah, explain it. Yeah, so stunt casting means when you bring on a guest star and they're a big name guest star. Now, of course, obviously in later years, we broke this rule. Will Ferrell, Kathy Bates, James Spader. Idris Elba.
很长一段时间里，有一条规则是我们不能进行任何噱头选角。是的。我不知道人们是否知道这意味着什么。是的，解释一下。是的，所以噱头选角意味着当你请来一位客串明星，而且他们是大牌明星。当然，在后来的几年里，我们显然打破了这个规则。威尔·法瑞尔、凯西·贝茨、詹姆斯·斯派德。伊德里斯·艾尔巴。
Yes, exactly. Timothy Oliphant. On and on. But for a long time, we had this rule against stunt casting. And this kind of fell into that. Once somebody was established to play a character, they were that person, or they didn't come back. The reason we broke the rule with Pam's mom and recasting
是的，没错。蒂莫西·奥利芬特。等等。但很长一段时间里，我们都有反对噱头选角的规则。这有点属于那一类。一旦有人被确定扮演一个角色，他们就是那个人，否则他们就不会回来。我们打破帕姆妈妈规则并重新选角的原因
is because the writers came up with a storyline that Michael would date Pam's mom. Do you remember that? Oh how could I forget that? Right? I know and Pam ends up slapping Michael but this storyline idea was just too good to pass up so they decided to recast and I hope that helps people with the whole two moms question. So I want to talk a little bit about the scene when Pam's mom finally arrives and you see Roy enter. Oh my God, and his outfit with his hair slicked down. His sweater, and he does that little dance to charm Pam's mom.
是因为编剧想出了一个迈克尔会和帕姆妈妈约会的故事情节。你还记得吗？哦，我怎么会忘记呢？对吧？我知道，帕姆最后打了迈克尔一巴掌，但这个故事构思太好了，不容错过，所以他们决定重新选角，我希望这能帮助人们解决关于两个妈妈的问题。所以我想谈谈帕姆妈妈终于到达时的场景，你看到罗伊进来了。哦，天哪，还有他那梳得油光发亮的头发。他的毛衣，他跳起那个小舞来吸引帕姆的妈妈。
So I'm gonna let you in on a little bit more of my actor prep here. And he asked her what music she wants. Yes. Okay, what is it? Well, you know, I had my Pam document and I was always asking myself questions about Pam that I thought were a mystery and I would answer them. Wait, I need to clarify for everyone.
所以我要让你们多了解一点我的演员准备工作。他问她想要什么音乐。是的。好的，是什么？嗯，你知道，我有我的帕姆文档，我总是问自己一些关于帕姆的问题，我觉得这些问题是个谜，我会回答它们。等等，我需要为大家澄清一下。
Jenna's Pam document wasn't given to her by Greg Daniels or any writers or producers. This was a document that Jenna made herself for her character. These are the kinds of things you learn in theater school, Angela. You can suck it. These are the things we're encouraged to do.
珍娜的帕姆文档并不是格雷格·丹尼尔斯或任何编剧或制片人给她的。这是珍娜为她的角色自己制作的文档。安吉拉，这些就是你在戏剧学校学到的东西。去你的吧。这些是我们被鼓励去做的事情。
I took some theater, I took theater classes. You know, just trained theater actors are encouraged. I took classes at HB Studios in New York City with Carol Rosenfeld, who was a protege of Uta Hagen. Thank you very much. All right, that's some pedigree. Thank you. All right. I's some pedigree. Thank you. All right.
我学过一些戏剧，我上过戏剧课。你知道，受过训练的戏剧演员是被鼓励这样做的。我在纽约市的HB工作室跟卡罗尔·罗森菲尔德上过课，她是乌塔·哈根的学生。非常感谢。好吧，那确实有些背景。谢谢。好吧。那确实有些背景。谢谢。好吧。
I got a blessing, oh. Well, in my document, I had asked myself the question, how did Pam and Roy end up together anyway? So I've answered sort of why I think they're still together, but how did they end up together? They seem so mismatched to me. Here was my backstory. Pam's family owned an appliance shop in downtown Scranton, like in the town
我得到了祝福，哦。嗯，在我的文档里，我问过自己一个问题，帕姆和罗伊到底是怎么走到一起的？所以我回答了为什么我认为他们还在一起，但他们是怎么走到一起的呢？在我看来他们太不般配了。这是我的背景故事。帕姆的家人在斯克兰顿市中心开了一家电器店，就像在镇上
square. And Roy in high school got a job working at the appliance store. And he was a great worker. He was very charming, as in the Roy you just saw here in the sweater. And so that was how their worlds collided. Because Pam was probably this little nerdy art student in high school, so I couldn't figure out how did she meet Roy. Who was probably a jock. Yeah. Yeah. And this was how.
广场那样。罗伊在高中时在电器店找了一份工作。他是个很棒的员工。他非常有魅力，就像你刚才在这里看到的穿着毛衣的罗伊一样。所以他们的世界就是这样碰撞的。因为帕姆在高中时可能是一个书呆子气的艺术生，所以我无法想象她是怎么认识罗伊的。他可能是一个运动员。是的。是的。就是这样。
He was very charming, and he asked her out, and they started dating. But because he worked there, the families became very enmeshed. They would barbecue together. So this is why and how she kind of can't get out of this relationship, even though now it's clear it's a mismatch, it's because the families are so conjoined. And do you think that Pam decided not to work
他非常有魅力，他约她出去，他们就开始约会了。但因为他在那里工作，两家人的关系变得非常紧密。他们会一起烧烤。所以这就是为什么她有点无法摆脱这段关系，即使现在很明显他们不般配，那是因为两家人的关系太紧密了。你认为帕姆决定不去
at the appliance store and go out, branch out, and then Roy followed her to the warehouse? Oh my gosh, Angela, I don't know, but I feel like I'm gonna go back and put that in my document right now. Because here's Pam, like, okay, I'm not gonna work at the family business. I need some space.
电器店工作，而是出去闯荡，然后罗伊跟着她去了仓库吗？天哪，安吉拉，我不知道，但我感觉我现在就要回去把这一点加到我的文档里。因为帕姆是这样的，好吧，我不会在家族企业工作了。我需要一些空间。
I need to figure out who I am. Yes! And then Roy's like, hey, I got a job at that warehouse. We'll be able to see each other every day. Oh my gosh. I find it interesting that Pam eats in the break room with Jim and not in the warehouse with Roy. Now we see Roy sometimes eat there.
我需要弄清楚我是谁。是的！然后罗伊说，嘿，我在那个仓库找了份工作。我们每天都能见到对方。天哪。我觉得很有趣的是，帕姆和吉姆在休息室吃饭，而不是和罗伊在仓库里吃。现在我们有时会看到罗伊在那里吃饭。
Yeah, they don't eat lunch together, do they? Not very often. And then Pam's mom has the moment in this episode where she whispers, which one is Jim? And you see John Krasinski's face. He's all pleased that he knows now that Pam, and by the way, in casino night, we know Pam calls her mom on the phone to, you know, share about what happened in the parking lot. Well, I just love the moment and John played
是的，他们不一起吃午饭，对吧？不经常。然后帕姆的妈妈在这一集里有一个时刻，她低声问，哪一个是吉姆？你看到了约翰·卡拉辛斯基的脸。他很高兴，因为他现在知道帕姆了，顺便说一句，在赌场之夜，我们知道帕姆给妈妈打了电话，你知道，分享了停车场发生的事情。嗯，我真的很喜欢那一刻，约翰演得
it so well where he sees his opportunity to introduce himself to Pam's mom. And he gets up the courage and he walks over right as Roy walks in and he just quickly takes like a piece of candy and goes back to his desk. And that kind of broke my heart for him. Lastly, from Dave Keckner, who plays Todd Packer, he said, Ang, please let everyone know I am nothing like Todd Packer in real life. Oh, and it's true everyone. I know. Dave is just a sweet, sweet, sweetheart, father of five. I know, and he said, he goes,
太好了，他看到了向帕姆妈妈介绍自己的机会。他鼓起勇气走过去，就在罗伊走进来的时候，他迅速拿了一块糖，回到了自己的座位上。那一刻让我为他感到心碎。最后，来自饰演托德·帕克的戴夫·凯克纳，他说，安吉拉，请告诉大家，我在现实生活中一点也不像托德·帕克。哦，这是真的，大家。我知道。戴夫是一个非常甜、非常甜、非常可爱的人，是五个孩子的父亲。我知道，他说，他说，
I just wish you and Jonah all the best. This is such a great idea. I just love it as a fan of the show. It's gotta be hard to believe that he is not like Todd Packer for some people, to imagine that if you met him, he is just the warmest, nicest, wonderful gentleman.
我祝你和乔纳一切顺利。这真是一个好主意。作为节目的粉丝，我真的很喜欢。对有些人来说，很难相信他不像托德·帕克，很难想象如果你见到他，他只是一个最热情、最友善、最棒的绅士。
I know. Yeah, I think sometimes you get known as this character, but he's nothing like that. I'm nothing like Angela Martin. This is true. You're a little bit like Pam. I am. All right, guys, that was sexual harassment.
我知道。是的，我想有时你会因为这个角色而出名，但他一点也不像那样。我一点也不像安吉拉·马丁。这是真的。你有点像帕姆。我是。好了，伙计们，那是性骚扰。
That was sexual harassment. We did it. Next week is Office Olympics with special guest director Paul Feig. He is the best dressed man in show business. For sure. Go to his Instagram. It is delightful.
那是性骚扰。我们做到了。下周是办公室奥运会，特邀导演保罗·费格。他是演艺界穿衣最有品位的人。肯定的。去看看他的Instagram。非常令人愉快。
Thank you for listening to Office Ladies' Second Drink. This episode was initially created in collaboration with Earwulf. Office Ladies is a presentation of Odyssey and is produced by Jenna Fisher and Angela Kinsey. Our executive producer is Cassie Jerkins and our audio engineer and associate producer is Daniella Silva.
感谢收听《办公室女士的第二杯》。本集最初是与Earwulf合作制作的。《办公室女士》是Odyssey的节目，由珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金赛制作。我们的执行制片人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音频工程师和副制片人是丹妮拉·席尔瓦。
Odyssey's executive producers are Jenna Wise-Berman and Leah Reese-Dennis. Office Ladies is mixed and mastered by Chris Basil. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Odyssey的执行制片人是珍娜·怀斯-伯曼和莉亚·里斯-丹尼斯。《办公室女士》由克里斯·巴兹尔混音和母带处理。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《橡胶树》。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。